So, Leute, da bin ich zur Abwechslung mal, ähm, was ist denn heute überhaupt?
Ne, aber Donnerstag. Donnerstagabend am Start.
Ich weiß nicht, ob heute MMO Kreiselgrind ist.
Kann sein, dass ich nachher weg muss.
Und ich dachte mir, ich mach mal am Anfang ein bisschen gescheite Musik an,
bis der Stream richtig anläuft.
Übrigens ein exzellenter Soundtrack.
Falls das Game jemand noch nicht gespielt hat,
absoluter POG-Soundtrack.
Massive POG-Soundtrack.
Wobei dann wahrscheinlich nicht jeder Bock drauf hat, könnte ich mir vorstellen.
Ich mach auch gleich aus, wenn der Stream richtig angelaufen ist.
Aber ich dachte, es muss mal was Gescheites sein.
Wir können nicht immer nur Nintendo gedudelt und sonst was haben.
Es muss mal was ordentliches.
Ähm, wo sind meine Mikrofonsettings?
Ich hab mir schon dreimal den Mixer aufgemalt, Alter.
Perfekt.
So ist richtig, genau.
Um auf fröhliches VM erstellen, uns ein bisschen einzustimmen.
Ich würde ja normalerweise mal ein bisschen was von meiner Lieblingsmusik anmachen.
Das Problem ist, Monkathos, ich kann nix anmachen.
So.
Okay.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, der Stream ist angelaufen.
Ich mach jetzt wieder etwas beruhigendere Klänge an.
Was machen wir denn heute an?
Mein Kontrastprogramm.
Also, wer das...
Also, ich hab das Game nicht gespielt, muss ich sagen, ja.
Aber das Spiel hat einen mega-nice Soundtrack.
Hat das jemand gespielt von euch, Metal Hellsinger?
Eigentlich, das ist quasi so ein Doom-Rhythmus-Game-Verschnitt.
Mit mega-nice Soundtrack.
Die haben sogar den System of a Dawn-Typ dabei hier.
Song-Modding.
Oh ja, nice.
Da kann man tatsächlich seine Lieblingsmusik reinhauen.
Es ist so dumm, dass...
Die ganzen Mainstream-Sachen auf Twitch...
Ich mach jetzt ein bisschen was Beruhigenderes an.
Es ist echt dumm, dass die ganzen Mainstream-Sachen so auf Twitch mittlerweile angekommen sind.
Und dass sie das gecheckt haben, dass es das gibt.
Weil früher konntest du ohne Probleme auch Monkathos-Musik laufen lassen.
Heute ist Tag der Modgis.
Nice.
Chat, Chat.
Einmal.
Es sind noch nicht viele da.
Ich weiß, ich weiß.
Aber ihr müsst jetzt einmal in den Chat gehen.
Und Mod-Check.
Hier.
Für die Mods.
Wir brauchen jetzt einmal von allen, die da sind.
Ich weiß, es sind noch nicht viele da.
Einmal Mod-Check für unsere Mods.
Können wir nachher nochmal machen.
Ja.
Perfekt.
Modgis.
So, machen wir mal ein bisschen was Beruhigenderes an.
Das ist mal Kontrastprogramm, oder?
Du musst es noch zu 100% fertig machen.
Ich muss es mir flaschen.
Vielleicht erst mal.
Also, ich glaube, ich habe es sogar...
Ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass ich es sogar gekauft habe.
Aber ich habe es weder runtergeladen noch gespielt.
Es könnte...
Ne, ne, runtergeladen.
Alles klar.
Es ist eine Stadt in Dänemark.
Gut.
Das...
Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass ich es gekauft habe auf Steam.
Ja, richtig.
Ich höre den Soundtrack.
Es gibt ein paar Sachen, da höre ich oft den Soundtrack und spiele es nicht.
Ich höre zum Beispiel auch richtig gerne noch den Warcraft.
Und teilweise die World of Warcraft Soundtracks.
Auch wenn ich das überhaupt nicht spiele.
Also, generell Blizzard-Musik aus den älteren Games.
Fand ich auch sehr nice.
Also, wenn man so ein bisschen auf so Orchester-Kram steht.
Ja, es ist halt echt doof, dass die ganzen Mainstream-Leute jetzt auch auf Twitch...
Twitch...
Also, die ganzen Plattenfirmen und sonst was, dass die alle mitgekriegt haben, dass es Twitch gibt.
Sonst hätte ich durchaus...
Ich habe ja schon...
Ich habe ja teilweise schon...
Ich habe...
Ich habe Glory Hammer mal angehabt.
Die Ärzte hatten wir ein paar Mal an früher.
Aber...
Ich kann es halt nichts mehr anmachen.
Du kannst halt nichts mehr anmachen, Gescheit.
Wobei, ganz ehrlich, bei den Ärzten bin ich mir gar nicht so sicher, ob da was passiert.
Aber...
Ja.
Also, es ist halt kacke.
Dass man...
Dass Twitch jetzt zu Mainstream ist in der Richtung.
Man hat keine Chance, immer hier irgendwelche Monka-Toss-Musik zu spielen.
Was ziemlich blöd ist.
Wollte ich sagen.
Ja, das ist aber auch doof.
Da hast du halt wieder riesen Acht.
Das ist halt kacke.
Also, ich hätte gerne ab und zu mal hier ein bisschen Musik, die ich...
Also, nicht so, dass ich mir das Nintendo-Gedudel nicht geben kann.
Aber ich hätte gerne auch mal ein bisschen ordentlich, was ich sonst auch Offstream höre, mal ab und zu im Stream angemacht.
Ich will euch ja nicht hier beschallen mit Heavy Metal die ganze Zeit im Stream.
Aber das kannst du nicht mehr machen.
Ja, nee.
Kannst du nicht mehr machen.
Ja, da könnte man mal ein bisschen Blind Guardian anmachen oder sowas.
Irgendwas, was ich halt selbst gerne höre.
Aber kannst du knicken hier im Stream auf Twitch mittlerweile.
Leider, ja.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das manche machen.
Ich habe das jetzt schon gesehen.
Bei manchen Streamern, dass die so 0815 Mainstream-Musik laufen haben.
Da weiß ich nicht genau, wie die das machen.
Wahrscheinlich haben die, wobei sie persönlich nicht, aber die Agentur oder was auch immer, die die vertritt.
Oder dieses Management-Ding, was die vertritt.
Wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Spezialabmachungen mit irgendwelchen Verwertungsgesellschaften oder so.
Das bringt dir ja nichts.
Du darfst den Kram ja trotzdem nicht spielen.
Es ist ja egal, ob es ein Wort ist oder nicht.
Du darfst es ja auch so und so nicht spielen.
Gut, bei dem anderen reduziert sich die Chance.
Da müssen sie dich quasi live erwischen.
Aber trotzdem.
Apple hat mich auch mal live erwischt vor Jahren.
Wo ich die Apple-Konferenz gestreamt habe und sie ein bisschen geflamed habe dabei.
Bam, Strike.
Aber der Strike, Leute.
Der Strike ist weg.
Der Apple-Strike ist weg.
Weil mittlerweile, da ist Apple glücklicherweise tatsächlich so großzügig gewesen.
Mittlerweile darf man die Apple-Konferenzen streamen.
Ich mache es aber nicht mehr.
Könnte ich mal.
Aber, ja.
Da haben sie dann, das haben sie dann zurückgenommen, dann als, also, quasi, als es erlaubt war.
Da haben sie wieder, vor, vor, vor einem Jahr oder zwei Jahren oder so, haben sie das, haben sie das gelöscht, den Strike.
Das war ja auch nicht von Apple selbst.
Das war ja von irgend so einer komischen XY, äh, super teure Anwaltskanzlei, die halt Apple vertritt.
Das ist halt, es ist, es ist halt schon ein bisschen kicke irgendwie.
Ist schon ein bisschen, es, es ist wirklich, ist wirklich doof, wie das mit Apple ist.
Was mit dem, äh, mit, mit Streamen und, und Musik ist.
Zum Beispiel kann man ein bisschen Powerwolf anmachen, ab und zu.
Für richtige Pregge-Time.
Wenn mal irgendwas funktioniert, wenn mal irgendwas nicht funktioniert, dann würden wir einfach eine Runde Preggen im Chat.
Ich würde Powerwolf anmachen.
Und das ist dann so viel Pregge, Pregge-Overload, dann muss es eigentlich funktionieren.
Aber, kannst du ja nicht machen.
Keine Chance.
Ja, vielleicht soll ich das auch machen.
Vielleicht soll ich das auch, vielleicht soll ich das auch.
Vielleicht soll ich das auch einfach.
Gut, mit zweiter Tonspur, die Sache ist halt die, dann können wir den Watt-Channel auf YouTube dicht machen.
Weil, na wobei, die laden das ja vom Watt runter und nicht live beim Stream dabei.
Dann müsste ich tatsächlich eine zweite Tonspur mit Gedudel machen für, für ein Watt.
Und hier im Stream könnten wir uns irgendwas, irgendwas härteres geben.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Also besser gesagt, also ich, ich, ich würde ja eh nicht im Stream jetzt.
Ich würde da wieder von vorn, also da gleich noch manchen noch mal rein machen.
Aber, ich weiß, dass derなく, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da.
Also, ich weiß, dass da viele nicht drauf stehen, ich halt schon.
Aber ab und zu wird es halt auch gut passen.
Aber du kannst halt nix anmachen.
Übrigens, soll ich euch mal was zeigen?
Ich mach mal kurz die VM an.
Vm-Ge.
De, Virtualisierungs-Ge.
So, also zu starten.
Ich mach mal meine, meinen normalen Linux-Vm-An.
Ich zeige euch mal was, und zwar.
Die Playlist, die fuckt mich jedes mal ab, weil die so ungleichmäßig laut ist.
Mal ist sie laut, mal ist sie leise.
Oder ein bisschen zu laut.
Ich brauch mal ein bisschen, bisschen was zackigeres heute.
Komm, machen wir wenigstens mal Crypt of the Necrodancer, das ist auch Pogger Soundtrack.
Das ist auch ein mega nices Game, beziehungsweise ein mega nices Soundtrack, wenn man auf sowas
steht.
So, also ich mach mal die VM an und ich zeige euch mal was, guck mal.
Wir gehen jetzt mal auf die Github Seite vom VM Champ und ihr werdet feststellen, achtet
mal hier drauf, es gibt seit 2 Stunden Version 2, stellt euch mal vor, Version 2, beziehungsweise
0.0.2, kurz runterladen und hier hin kopieren, dass ich euch ein bisschen was zeigen kann.
Bevor wir uns dann TrueNAS angucken.
Okay.
Äh, Repos, Scripts, Help, da muss es rein?
Ja.
Excellent.
Äh, wir machen da heute gar nix mit.
Wir machen heute TrueNAS, wir gucken uns heute TrueNAS Gale an, aber ich kann das auch
kurz zeigen, wenn du willst, ja.
Wir haben ja Zeit, eventuell, ich weiß nicht genau, ob wir Zeit haben, weil noch ist keiner
da.
Aber vielleicht gibt's nachher wieder Kreiselgrind, muss ich mal, muss ich mal gucken.
So, ich mach mal kurz hier die Terminal zu, Terminal zu.
Dann machen wir einfach mal, das müssen wir wahrscheinlich eh machen, ich mach mal Package
Updates und starte, starte neu, dachte, das verdammte Spiel, wie PNPM hat, kann das heute
vielleicht.
Okay, ich mach mal nix, während das eine läuft, ja.
Es ist eh ein Kernel Update dabei, wenn ein Kernel Update dabei ist, heißt, ich muss
auf jeden Fall rebooten.
Warum streamst du den Kreiselgrind nicht?
Weil ich glaube, dass die meisten Leute Dark Edge of Camelot nicht so spannend finden,
ich hab ja ein paar Mal RvR gestreamt.
Das kam erstaunlich gut an, das ein oder andere Mal, ich mein, es ist halt ein Ur-Ur-Ur-Alt-Game
und die meisten haben da, glaube ich, keinen Bock drauf, außerdem will ich ein bisschen
mit den Leuten schwätzen und will mich nicht so sehr auf den Stream konzentrieren.
Das ist, das ist richtig, was Tribes schreibt, nur um neue zu erstellen.
Warte mal, ich kann dir das gleich zeigen, wir rebooten jetzt mal, aus irgendwelchen
Gründen kann ich nicht rebooten.
Das hatte ich ja noch nie.
Ja, ja.
Ja.
Das hatte ich ja noch nie.
Das hatte ich ja noch nie, dass Reboot einen Lag hatte beim Ausführen und jetzt hängt
irgendwas.
Ah, ja, da müssen wir mal kurz warten, ob das sich von alleine beendet, wenn es sich
nicht von alleine beendet, dann muss ich die VM halt abschalten, ausschalten, Force Off,
Force Offen.
Dann kann ich euch noch was anderes erzählen.
No Limit, ja, wir warten mal kurz, wir warten mal kurz.
Eine Minute können wir warten, wenn nicht, ein bisschen Steuerung C hämmern, wenn nicht,
kann ich euch noch was lustiges erzählen.
Ich hatte ja am Mittwoch, meinen letzten Arbeitstag, New World Let's Play Monk, es ist alter New
World.
Ich hatte ja letzten, letzten Mittwoch, also was heißt letzten Mittwoch, gestern, das
hört sich jetzt so letzten Mittwoch an wie letztes, gestern war das.
Letzter Mittwoch, hört sich das so an.
Also, ja, mach noch GitHub rein, ist eine gute Idee.
Also.
Ich hatte ja meinen letzten Arbeitstag und da habe ich meine ganze Hardware zurückgegeben.
Das waren ja insgesamt zwei Notebooks, das Handy, Tastatur, Maus, ganz, ganzes Geschiss.
Ja, alles, alles, was ich hatte, so Docking Station, Curved Monitor, alle Dinge, alle Sachen
zurückgegeben.
So, und ich hatte das Netzteil für mein iPhone nicht dabei.
Ach guck mal, jetzt, jetzt hat es funktioniert mit ausschalten.
Easy.
Ich hatte das Netzteil für mein iPhone nicht dabei.
Also dieses, dieses billige.
Okay, das ist, das ist nicht billig.
Das ist Apples kostbar, ja, 50 Euro, das, das USB-C Netzteil von meinem, von meinem
iPhone.
Dann haben die gemeint, ah, sie wollen das eigentlich lieber, lieber komplett, also
sie wollen das jetzt so eigentlich nicht, sie wollen das, wollen das lieber mit Netzteil
haben.
Habe ich gesagt, heute ist mein letzter Arbeitstag, also ich kann es auch einfach wieder mitnehmen
und dann kriegt ihr es nicht.
Das ist dann auch so, ja, dann, dann geben sie es jetzt doch her.
Ich meine, hey.
Ich meine, hey, die hätten auch sagen können, ja, dann fahren sie gefährlichst heim und
holen sie den Kram, ja, aber da wollten sie dann keinen Stress machen, aber das fand ich
witzig.
Erst so nach dem, ah, das können wir eigentlich so nicht nehmen, da fehlt das Netzteil, ja,
es ist mein letzter Tag, ich kann es einfach auch wieder mitnehmen.
Ah, nee, nee, nee, nee, geben sie es, geben sie es einfach her.
Ja, aber ich meine, scheiße auf dieses Netzteil, Mann, was wollen die damit?
Vor allem, die haben die Geräte selbst irgendwo geleast, also insofern ist doch, ist doch
scheißegal.
So.
Ja gut, es ist ein Apple-Netzteil.
Ein Apple-Netzteil.
Was kostet, okay, lass uns das mal kurz, lass uns das mal kurz kontrollieren.
Apple-USB-C-Netzteil.
Dafür kriegst du ja schon drei China-Chinesen-Netzteile, Mann.
Ich habe, ich habe mir letztens einen China-Chinesen, ach so, ich habe mich verguckt.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Das ist tatsächlich ein anderes, das ist nicht das Richtige.
Das ist das Falsche.
Das sieht, das sieht tatsächlich anders aus.
Das andere ist aber auch nicht billiger.
Das hier ist, glaube ich, das Richtige.
Ja, das ist das Richtige, kostet aber auch 40 Euro.
Das kostet aber einfach, 18 Volt letztes Jahr, das kostet aber, kostet aber auch einfach
40 Euro.
Ey, ich habe mir letztens ein China-Chinesen-Netzteil gekauft, 140 Watt-Netzteil, USB-C.
Oh, Alter.
Das ist so, warum ist der Scheiß auf einmal so teuer?
Ich glaube, ich habe mir das Netzteil gekauft.
Aber.
Garantiert nicht für 80 Euro.
Ich, ich kann jetzt, egal.
Das fand ich tatsächlich ganz nice, weil du kannst insgesamt drei Geräte volle Pulle
da dran laden.
Du hast zweimal USB-C, kannst darauf Lightning oder halt, oder halt USB-A-Anschluss.
Aber ein bisschen teuer ist es trotzdem.
So.
So, ja gut, die VM ist neu gestartet.
Ich habe bis heute legit kein USB-C-Netzteil, ich habe, naja, die neuen Netzteile, die
alle ein bisschen mehr Leistung haben, die sind meistens mit mindestens einem USB-C ausgestattet.
Das heißt, man hat dann ein USB-C-Netzteil.
Man kann ja USB-C immer noch auf alles andere umwursten, was du willst, ja.
Du kannst USB-C auf Mini, Micro, ähm, Lightning, USB-C auf USB-C soll es auch geben.
Kannst du, kannst du eh alles machen.
Also das ist nicht wild.
Es gibt sogar mittlerweile Kabel, die sind ganz nice.
Die haben hinten einen USB-Stecker.
Und auf der anderen Seite kannst du auswählen zwischen Lightning, USB-C und, also so Dreifachkabel.
Da habe ich immer eins, da habe ich immer eins im Rucksack dabei.
USB-C, Kabel, Micro USB, USB-C und, und Lightning.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Sowas in der Richtung.
Es ist nicht, es ist nicht wirklich genau das, aber sowas in der Richtung ist es.
Guck.
Da hast du hinten USB-C oder normales USB und vorne kannst du dir halt aussuchen.
Mini, äh, Micro USB, USB-C oder Lightning.
So eins habe ich immer dabei im Rucksack.
Das ist enorm praktisch.
Mit einer Powerbank.
Weil ich habe keinen Bock mehr, dass ich, dass ich mal in der doofen Situation lande.
Man macht so viel mittlerweile mit seinem Handy.
Da sind so viele Informationen und wichtige Sachen drauf.
Sei es auch Navigation mit dem Handy, wenn du irgendwo bist, wo du, wo du dich nicht auskennst oder so.
Deswegen, ich habe immer ne, glaub, 8000...
12.000, 12.000 Milliampere-Stunden Powerbank im Rucksack.
Die du zur Not auch über Solar aufladen kannst.
Auch wenn das fragwürdig ist, wie schnell das geht.
Das habe ich noch nie ausprobiert.
Ja, sowas ist auch nicht schlecht.
MonkaS.
So, also ich habe neu gestartet.
Dann würde ich sagen, ja, ich zeige euch mal, ich zeige euch mal die neue Version vom 4M Champ.
Vom Anfang.
Und mir ist das, mir ist die Musik zu nervös.
Ich, ich muss doch, ich muss doch wieder entspannte, entspannte Mario-Klänge anmachen.
Sonst wird das, sonst wird das nix.
Kann ich mich nicht, nicht, nicht konzentraten.
Excellent.
Du, du, du, du, du, du, du.
Ja.
Okay, das ist doch das Beste.
Ich, ich mache das übrigens auch gerne an.
Ich habe das teilweise sogar solche Playlists bei, bei mir auf der Arbeit auf dem Kopfhörer an.
Weil ich das einfach sehr entspannt finde, Nintendo-Musik.
Man kommt aus Lebens...
Als nächstes.
Also entweder, entweder als nächstes.
Oder ich lasse mich tatsächlich noch mal zwischenzeitlich zum Abschalten von Bad Company 2 aus.
Das glaube ich aber nicht.
Ich glaube, ich, ich, also entweder als nächstes oder als übernächstes.
Ich meine, ich muss jetzt mal langsam machen.
Ich fange nächste Woche Montag an.
Da wird es mal Zeit, dass ich euch zumindest mal die Bewerbungen alles zeige.
Das ist, ja, das ist tatsächlich so, wenn man das macht.
Die Primers.
Heute, letzter Tag oder morgen.
Gestern.
Ich habe alles abgegeben.
Ich bin, ich bin, ich bin auch alles los geworden.
Also ich habe, ich habe kein Handy mehr, kein, kein Notebook mehr, nichts.
Ich könnte mich theoretisch remote noch einloggen.
Aber wozu sollte ich das, wozu sollte ich das machen?
Hat ja überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Ich könnte theoretisch noch in Teams gucken.
Aber wozu sollte ich das machen?
Hat ja überhaupt keinen Sinn.
War ich nicht.
Bin weg.
Wie fühlt es sich an?
Sehr merkwürdig.
Im Prinzip.
Im Prinzip so, wie ich das gesagt habe in dem, in meinem letzten Video.
Sehr, sehr, sehr merkwürdig.
Also, aktuell, aktuell bin ich im Kopf eher noch so, als hätte ich zwei, drei Tage Urlaub.
Und, nee, bis jetzt hat es noch nicht hingehauen mit uns, das zweite, das zweite, den zweiten Teil des Videos aufzunehmen.
Also, wie ist es, arbeitslos zu sein?
Nee, ich bin hier, ich bin ja nicht arbeitslos.
Also, wenn man so wählt, schon.
Aber ich, mein Arbeitsvertrag läuft ja noch bis zum 31.03.
Und ab dem 1. läuft der neue.
Also, ich bin wahrscheinlich so die, die, die, ähm, Nanosekunde zwischen dem, dem Umschalten hier dazwischen mal kurz arbeitslos.
Aber den Verlust bei der Rente werde ich überleben.
Es ist sehr merkwürdig.
Es ist, es ist auf jeden Fall sehr merkwürdig.
Also, im Kopf ist es bei mir jetzt so, ich denke, ich denke die ganze Zeit noch, ich habe jetzt einfach Urlaub bis nächste Woche so.
Und dann geht es bestimmt weiter.
Aber es geht halt nicht weiter.
Was ja auch gut ist.
Ich meine, ich habe mir das ja absichtlich ausgesucht, dass es nicht weiter geht.
Ich hätte ja, ich hätte ja weitermachen können.
Und, was ich, was ich heute noch erfahren habe, was mich auch, was mich auch wieder zu der, ja bekomme ich.
Weil ich fette Stonks habe.
Also, die gesetzliche Rente kannst du vergessen bei mir.
Aber ich habe Stonks und ich habe noch die letzten Jahre betriebliche Altersvorsorge gemacht, wo beide Seiten eingezahlt haben.
Und das lohnt sich tatsächlich, weil du kriegst ja quasi das, was du einbezahlst, noch mal mindestens verdoppelt vom Arbeitgeber.
Und das hat sich gelohnt.
Außerdem habe ich ein Haus.
Außerdem habe ich genug Kohle.
Ich habe Stonks.
Also, ich glaube, rententechnisch ist bei mir nicht so das Problem.
Aber gesetzliche Rente kannst du wahrscheinlich wirklich vergessen, ja.
Hast du dein Arbeitszeug nicht?
Ja, sie haben es hinbekommen.
Sie haben es, sie haben es endlich hingekriegt.
Am letzten Tag konnte ich, konnte ich abholen.
Ja.
Also, ich werde garantiert nicht bis, bis 67 oder so arbeiten.
Irgendwas muss man ja auch mal von seiner Kohle haben.
Muss man irgendwann ja auch mal was davon machen.
Ja, also, wie gesagt, das ist ja, ist ja merkwürdig.
Aber nächste Woche geht es ja, geht es ja schon wieder los.
Da ist ja nicht so viel Zeit, sich Gedanken drüber zu machen.
So, ich wollte gerade noch irgendwas sagen zu irgendeiner Chatnachricht.
Aber ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Darüber auch ein Video.
Was über meine Rente und Stonks.
Boah, ich weiß nicht.
Ich glaube, da gibt, bin ich nicht der Richtige, da großartig was zu Stonks zu erzählen.
Zumal meine Stonks dieses Jahr.
Ähm, naja.
Wenn ich nicht so geil war.
Arubas Arbeitszeugnis.
Ja, das könnte ich alles in einem machen.
Ach ja, genau.
Sehr gut, siehst du.
Chat, ich muss sagen, sehr nice.
High IQ Chat.
Man sieht, die ganzen Prime Subscriptions zahlen sich eindeutig aus.
Also, die Hirnleistung des Chats ist, also würde ich schon sagen, dass das, dass das eindeutig auch Chat GPT übersteigt.
Die hätten sich eigentlich, die hätten sich eigentlich sparen können, diese ganze AI Entwicklung.
Die hätten einfach auf den Wubblos Twitch Chat zurückgreifen müssen.
Aber das wussten die halt nicht.
Richtig, richtig weirdchamping für die.
Millionen reingesteckt und in Wirklichkeit haben wir schon längst was besseres.
Gut.
Also, ja, dazu wollte ich was sagen.
Korrekt.
Du wolltest was sagen, was du an deinem letzten Tag erfahren hast.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Nicht, nicht am letzten Tag.
Äh, heute tatsächlich.
Heute.
Mein letzter Tag war ja gestern.
Heute habe ich das noch erfahren.
Und zwar habe ich erfahren, dass, oder da bin ich wieder zu dem Schluss gekommen, dass ich da genau zur richtigen Zeit, zum richtigen Zeitpunkt abgehauen bin.
Und zwar, was ich heute erfahren habe, ist, dass noch zwei weitere Kollegen wohl gekündigt haben.
Und die haben jetzt schon Probleme, dass das alles aufrecht erhalten, aufrecht zu erhalten.
Und wenn dann noch zwei weitere fehlen, ist es komplett vorbei.
Kannst komplett knicken.
Es klappt jetzt nicht mehr.
Und dann ist es komplett unmöglich.
Ich sag mal, ich sage nicht, dass ich mich jetzt freue, wirklich, dass es da den Bach runter geht.
Das stimmt nicht.
Weil ich kenne ja immer noch genug Leute, die dort arbeiten.
Und, äh, ja, wo ich nicht will, dass es denen jetzt tagtäglich beschissen geht.
Aber man sieht, also, ich bin wieder immer zu dem, ich komme immer wieder zum Schluss, es war genau der richtige Zeitpunkt abzuhauen.
Rennen alle Entwickler weg?
Nee, Entwickler rennen auch weg.
Also, ich habe gehört, dass...
Also, ich habe gehört, dass letztes Jahr, Ende letzten Jahres angeblich...
Ich weiß nicht, ob das stimmt.
Ähm, also, wie gesagt, man hat es um fünf Ecken gehört.
Über 100 Leute...
Oder, sagen wir mal, so...
Abgerundet 100 Leute, um die 100 Leute gekündigt haben Ende letzten Jahres.
Das ist extrem viel für den Laden.
Normalerweise wurde es die letzten Jahre eher immer nur mehr.
Aber gut, man...
Management-Fail, einer nach dem anderen, da muss man sich nicht wundern, wenn das so...
Wenn das so bergab geht.
Man hat es ja auch kommen sehen.
Es ist jetzt nicht, dass es von heute auf morgen irgendwie auf einmal da gewesen wäre.
Kann man jetzt leaken?
Nö, ich leake das nicht.
Ich leake das auch in Zukunft nicht.
Warum soll ich das machen?
Ja, also, wie gesagt, das habe ich erfahren, dass jetzt noch zwei weitere Leute abhauen.
Dann ist komplett, komplett vorbei.
So, gut.
Dann können wir jetzt mit dem weitermachen, was ich euch jetzt zeigen wollte.
Bevor wir uns Trunas angucken.
Dann erzähle ich euch auch, warum wir uns Trunas angucken.
Kann mir fix einer helfen und mir sagen, wie das Video mit dem neuen Dateiendung-Hack heißt.
Boah...
Ich habe gedacht, ich habe es vielleicht in der History...
Ne, keine Ahnung mehr.
Keine...
Keine Ahnung mehr.
Ich meine, du kannst einfach ins Wort gucken.
Du kannst ins Wort gucken und durchskippen, bis du es gefunden hast.
Weil dann sieht man ja die URL vom Video.
Beziehungsweise siehst du auch den Titel und dann kannst du den Titel einfach so...
Ja, das ist es.
Genau.
Alter, Mordgewitter wirklich way, way too high IQ.
Mordges Wissens.
Der Streamtitel ist ein bisschen bait.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich habe, ich habe Trunas Scale noch nie ausprobiert.
Aber ich sehe im Heimbereich, dass ganz viele Leute Unraid, Trunas, Trunas weniger, muss
man sagen, Trunas weniger, Proxmox und Unraid verwenden.
Und Trunas ja selber sagt, sie machen, ja, Webinterface für Shares erstellen.
Und Disc Handling und sowas.
Aber auch Container und VMs.
Also ist das schon Konkurrenz.
Ich denke, so würden die sich selbst auch sehen.
So, aber und das Beste ist, ja, das ist richtig nice.
Deswegen läuft Docker out of the box mit allem Linux-Geschiss drauf.
Ja, das ist nice.
Das ist übrigens auch der Grund, warum ich mir das jetzt nochmal angucke.
Also, bevor wir anfangen mit Trunas.
Ich habe heute eine neue Version released vom Unraid.
Und der Radio, Radio?
Wie hieß er denn?
Radiosignal oder sowas?
Wo ist er?
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Jemand aus dem Chat hatte eben auch gefragt, was macht das Tool?
Deswegen zeige ich es euch.
Ach da, Radiosignale.
Ich war doch gar nicht so schlecht mit Radio.
Deswegen zeige ich es euch nochmal kurz.
Und mit dem Hinweis, es gibt ja, es gibt jetzt Version 2.
Es gibt übrigens auch bald, ich habe mir vorhin schon eins erstellt.
Ein Arch Repo dafür.
Also ein Arch Repo dafür.
Das heißt, ich habe ein Arch Repo dafür.
Also der Worti hat eins erstellt und ich erstelle jetzt noch ein, ein Binary Repo.
Da kann man sich das über den Arch Package Manager installieren.
Ich habe vorhin Version 2 gepusht.
Was ist neu?
Es ist übrigens, ich habe noch was vergessen reinzuschreiben.
Recreate.
Was ist neu?
Option on
Recreate
Overwrite
Oh, ich will mir das jetzt richtig
schreiben. Over
Write Option
on
OEM Start. So.
Update.
Wie viel Stars? 24 erst
noch. So, äh, da gibt's
ein paar Neuigkeiten dazu.
Hab ich heute Vormittag mich ein bisschen drum gekümmert.
Ich dachte mir, ich hab ja jetzt zwei Tage
beziehungsweise inklusive dem Wochenende vier Tage
sonst nichts großartig zu tun. Können ein bisschen
Progress-Stells machen. Muss ich auch nicht im Stream machen.
Da geht's auch schneller. Da krieg ich auch was auf die Reihe.
Weil im Stream ist immer schwierig da.
Äh, da bin ich so viel am Schwätzen, da krieg ich kaum
was auf die Reihe. Das ist immer sehr schleppend und langsam
im Stream was zu programmieren. Aber
ist natürlich cool, weil man vieles erklären kann und
zeigen. Aber es geht halt nicht so schnell, wenn man alleine
vorm Rechner sitzt.
Also ich hab ein paar Sachen eingebaut.
Man kann VMs jetzt neu starten.
Wenn man eine VM anlegt, die es schon gibt,
zeig ich euch gleich, dann kann man die
überschreiben.
Man kann Custom-Scripts ausführen nach dem Erstellen
der VM. Man kann die CPU-Cores customisieren,
wie man haben will. Es gibt jetzt mehr
Distributionen zur Auswahl und
man sieht im List-Command ein bisschen mehr
Optionen.
Also was ist das für ein Tool? Auch wenn wir da heute
nicht dran weiterprogrammieren. Das ist
was, was ich die letzte Woche
im Homeoffice erstellt
hab.
Ja,
wie gesagt, meine Motivation auf der
aktuellen Arbeit hielt sich in Grenzen. Zumal
man sagen muss, das ist ein
Tool,
was natürlich auch jedem Linux-Admin nutzt,
deswegen gar nicht mal so schlecht
investierte Zeit. Snapshots erstellen.
Das Problem bei Snapshots erstellen.
Ich glaube, ich bin mir nicht sicher, warum
es nicht geht. Ich glaube, das kann man
nicht mit temporären VMs machen.
Ich habe mir das aber schon als To-Do
aufgeschrieben, ob ich das nicht irgendwie
einbauen kann, weil ab und zu werden
Snapshots zumindest auch temporär ganz
praktisch. Aber ich glaube, das funktioniert
mit temporären VMs nicht.
So, also wie gesagt, ich habe Version 2.
Version 2.
Nicht zu laut sagen. Sollte sie die Rechte
einfordern. Good luck, Herr Pfann.
So, und
ich habe das
letzte Woche programmiert.
Und das ist ein Tool, mit dem man,
man sieht es ja hier im Bild, ich zeige es euch auch gleich.
Das ist ein Tool, wo man
lokal auf seiner Linux-Kiste
mit einem Kommando sich schnell
Test-VMs erstellen kann.
Manchmal braucht man echte
VMs. Natürlich, wenn man eine Test-VM
will, kann man auch einfach hier in den
VM-Workstation gehen. New Virtual
Machine, weiter, weiter, weiter, ISO einhängen,
installieren. Aber das dauert halt.
Da brauchst du ja 5-10 Minuten,
bis du ein fertiges Betriebssystem hast, was
funktioniert. Und ich will da halt
5-20 Sekunden drauf warten,
dann soll es da sein.
So, ähm.
Du hast
dafür die VM-Champ geworben.
Das Tool nutzt nicht VM,
nein, das geht mit KVM.
Was ist für KVM? Steht ja auch hier.
KVM, QEMU-Lib wird.
So, GNOME-Boxes ist auch nix.
Das ist nix für den Anwendungsfall, weil das ist ein GUI-Tool.
Ich will auf der Kommandozeile VMs
erstellen und mich direkt per SSH verbinden.
Warum VMs? Ganz einfach,
weil nicht für alles
ein Container immer
das Beste ist
zum Testen. Zum Beispiel,
also der offensichtlichste Fall ist,
wenn du
Kernel-Module laden willst
oder unloaden willst oder irgendwas testen willst,
das kannst du in jeglicher Container-Lösung
natürlich vergessen.
Wirst du nachher LXC erklären?
Nö.
Ich mach nix mit LXC hier.
Ah, du meinst bei TrueNAS?
Ja, mal gucken. Ich hab mir TrueNAS noch nie angeguckt.
Was ist denn bei deiner
Bar oben der lange
Underscore-Strich?
Das ist CPU-Auslastung.
Ich hab 8 Kerne. Ich zeig dir das mal.
Ich mach mal ein bisschen Last.
Ich geb mal einfach in meinem Terminal Yes aus.
Guck dir mit auffallen. Ich hab 8 Kerne
und die Kerne sind dann unterschiedlich
ausgelastet.
Jetzt haben wir eine schöne gleichmäßige
Auslastung, wie du auch hier siehst.
Also, ich hab jetzt CPU-Auslastung.
Hier oben siehst du halt CPU-Auslastung.
Dass das tatsächlich funktioniert,
kann ich dir auch daran zeigen.
Wir machen mal 2 hoch.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 8
nach BC. Wie?
Lull. Ich hab BC nicht installiert.
Seriously?
Warum das denn nicht?
Keck, wait.
So.
Guck, jetzt berechnen wir was in BC
und du siehst, es ist auch nur ein CPU-Core,
der...
Das I.O. im Terminal
dann schnell genug, um CPU-Auslastung zu haben.
Na klar.
Ich mein,
der I.O. ist ja
im Prinzip nur durch
CPU
Belastbarkeit beschränkt und vielleicht
bisschen GPU. Ja, ja.
Klar.
Wenn du so schnell wie geht
im Terminal Sachen ausgibst, dann macht
das auch CPU-Last. Ist zwar eine ziemlich sinnlose
Sache, um CPU-Last zu erzeugen, aber okay.
So, du siehst, es ist nur ein CPU-Kern.
Ähm, CPU-Kern.
Wir können übrigens auch S
Dings hier verwenden für
Stresstest.
Stresstest. BÄM.
100% CPU-Auslastung
auf allen Cores. Aber man sieht das.
Man sieht das halt. Man sieht das halt schlecht. Deswegen mach ich das lieber
mit BC. Da können wir nämlich auch mal
ein paar Sachen in den Hintergrund schicken.
So, eine CPU voll ausgelastet, zwei
CPUs voll, drei, vier CPUs voll ausgelastet.
So, BÄM. Siehst du,
genau hier. Vier CPUs voll ausgelastet.
Das ist tatsächlich...
Und jetzt können wir noch Terminal auslasten.
Bam.
Jetzt ist es gut.
Jetzt ist es gut ausgelastet.
Ja, ist eine nice Anzeige.
Weil ganz im Ernst, normalerweise interessiert dich ja gar nicht so genau, welche CPU jetzt wie ausgelastet ist.
Wenn du das genau wissen willst, machst du H-Top auf.
Oder wie die coolen Leute machen, B-Top.
Weil das viel cooler aussieht.
Und das alle dann immer geil finden, wenn man sich B-Top angucken kann.
Aber ich muss sagen, H-Top ist für mich immer noch beste.
Und ansonsten willst du ja eigentlich nur wissen, ob viel abgeht im Hintergrund auf deinem Rechner oder nicht.
Und da ist die Anzeige hier oben ganz optimal aus.
So.
Aber kommen wir jetzt nochmal ganz kurz zurück dazu.
Was man damit machen kann.
Also im Prinzip ist das Ganze einfach.
Ach ja, ich wollte ja noch eine Sache sagen.
Also manchmal ist es halt so, man braucht immer noch lokal eine VM zum Testen, weil es ein Docker-Container eben nicht macht.
Zum Beispiel, offensichtlich können Module laden und unloaden.
Und das kannst du halt mit Container-Lösungen nie machen.
Weil das alles immer nur quasi ein weiterer Prozess im Host-Betriebssystem-Kernel ist.
Also Container sind ja eine Illusion, wenn du so willst.
Container ist ja kein Container in dem Sinn.
Das Container hört sich tatsächlich an wie so eine eigene Box.
Was ist ja gar nicht.
Na doch, eine eigene Box trifft es eigentlich ganz gut.
Aber es ist jetzt kein eigenes System, auch wenn es auf den ersten Blick so aussieht.
Ein Container ist stinknormaler Prozess wie jeder andere Prozess.
Also wenn ich jetzt das hier, also wenn ich jetzt hier meine Berechnungen starte auf meinem Host oder ob ich die in einem Docker-Container starte, ist es vollkommen egal.
Das ist kaum ein Unterschied für mein Host-Betriebssystem, was es macht.
Der Unterschied ist nur, dass es ein paar...
Der Container ist a lie quasi.
Der einzige Unterschied ist zwischen so ausführen oder dieses ganze Ding in irgendeinem Docker-Container.
Der einzige Unterschied zwischen dem Docker-Run ausführen ist, dass es ein paar Send-Boxing-Funktionen, wobei das fast auch schon ein Tick viel gesagt ist, ein paar Send-Boxing-Funktionen gibt, dass sich Prozesse nicht in die Quere kommen.
Zum Beispiel, dass die, was haben wir da alles, der Host-Name beispielsweise für jeden Prozess anders sein kann.
Die Disk ein bisschen anders sein kann.
Die Uhrzeit, glaube ich, sogar auch ein bisschen anders sein kann für jeden Prozess.
Also es gibt ein paar vorgefertigte Namespaces, nennt sich das in Linux.
Also Container gibt es eigentlich in dem Sinn nicht.
Container sind eine Zusammenfassung aus zwei Features im Linux-Körnel, auch wenn das unter Container läuft.
Das sind C-Groups und das sind Namespaces.
C-Groups ist die, nennen wir es mal Send-Boxing-Funktionalität.
Wobei ich mir auch nicht 100%...
sicher bin, was genau alles jetzt zum Aufgabengebiet von C-Groups, C-Groups 2 ist es ja mittlerweile, fehlt.
Also C-Groups ist so ein bisschen das Send-Boxing-System und Namespaces ist das, um Prozessen in Containern andere Sachen vorzugaukeln, als sie eigentlich auf dem Host sind.
Zum Beispiel der Host-Name, die Uhrzeit und solche Geschichten.
Aber Container in dem Sinn gibt es nicht.
Das ist eine Zusammenfassung aus Features im Linux-Körnel.
So und es ist kein Unterschied wirklich, großartig, ob ich den Prozess in einem Docker-Container ausführe oder hier lokal auf der Shell ausführe.
Das macht kaum einen Unterschied, das läuft alles als Prozess hier auf meiner Host-Kiste und fertig.
Deswegen, wenn du Docker-Container startest als Root zum Beispiel, da würde ich mich nicht auf die Send-Box-Funktionalitäten verlassen.
Dass da nichts passieren kann.
So und deswegen gehen halt manche Sachen nicht.
Nachdem jeder Prozess halt innerhalb meines Host-Betriebssystems läuft, verwenden die auch alle den Kernel von meinem Host-Betriebssystem.
Also in dem Fall ist es 628.
Und wenn ich in einem Container Kernel-Module laden und entladen will, dann geht das nicht.
Beziehungsweise, beziehungsweise...
Ich könnte das machen auf dem Host und dann wäre es halt für alle Container da.
Also es ist...
Manche Sachen sind blöd im Container.
Was auch blöd ist in Containern zu testen zum Beispiel ist Systemd, Unit-Files und solche Geschichten.
Also wenn ich wirklich das starten will wie ein vollständiges System.
Zumindest mit Docker ist es ein bisschen schwierig.
Du kannst sowas mit LXC machen, wenn du komplette OS-Images bootest.
Aber selbst da hast du ein paar Probleme.
Also wenn du solche Sachen machen willst, sind Container manchmal nicht die beste Wahl.
Für 90% von...
Lass mal die Anwendung bauen, lass mal die Anwendung testen oder sowas.
Dann...
Ist ein Container eine super Geschichte, weil es ist zackig, es ist schnell, es braucht nicht viel RAM.
RAM-Overhead ist ja der hauptsächliche Knackpunkt an VMs.
Also sagen wir mal, Disk und RAM-Overhead.
CPU ist gar nicht so das Problem.
Die CPU-Leistung in einer VM...
Ist nahezu gleich zum Haus-Betriebssystem.
Was eine VM eben...
Was an einer VM doof ist, ist, dass eine VM RAM braucht.
Also deutlich mehr RAM.
Ich meine, guck dir mal.
Wenn ich jetzt meine Berechnung hier ausführe, dann brauche ich RAM genau für diese zwei Befehle.
Beziehungsweise was PC an RAM braucht zum Berechnen.
Sind ein paar Kilobyte wahrscheinlich unter der Haube.
Wenn ich das gleich in einer VM starten will, dann muss ich ja...
Ein komplett neues...
Linux booten.
Und das ist ein ganz offensiver, eigener Kernel.
Eigenen Libraries.
Einen User-Tools.
Alles mögliche.
Dementsprechend ist das eigentliche Problem an VMs, nicht so sehr die CPU-Leistung.
Auch wenn das manche Leute denken, das eigentliche Problem an VMs ist, warum es im großen Stil nicht so der Weisheitsletzterschluss ist,
ist schlicht ergreifend die Speicherauslastung.
Also der Speicherverbrauch.
Du brauchst halt viel viel mehr Speicher...
und halt auch für dein Image brauchst du mehr.
brauchst du mehr speicher das ist halt ein unterschied ja debian server mit 34
mb ram verbrauch ja das sind aber du siehst das ist quasi eines der
minimalsten systeme die du laufen lassen kannst brauchen mindestens 34 mb in der
vm mein kommando hier zum laufen zu lassen braucht 500 kilobyte und das ist
halt ein riesen unterschied wenn du viele davon ausführen willst so und das
ist eigentlich das hauptproblem an vms oder was heißt hauptproblem so also so
eines der probleme die man bekommt wenn man im großen stil vms benutzt das ist
halt im vergleich zu konnte er einfach der overhead was speicher anbetrifft zu
disk als auch arbeitsspeicher es gibt ein paar bestrebungen dazu das noch
weiter zu verbessern ich weiß nicht ob ihr das kennt firecracker vm ob sie
etwas von amazon das sind noch mal besonders minimalistische vms ich glaube
das ist irgendwas von amazon wenn ich nicht
ganz wenn ich nicht ganz verkehrt liege das sind noch mal besonders
minimalistische vms allerdings muss sagen vms werden immer dadurch dass du
einen eigenen kernel starten muss immer mehr ram verbrauchen als ein container
und deswegen das ist halt eines der vorteile von containern beziehungsweise
nachteile von vms dafür haben vms andere vorteile
erstens sind vms noch besser sandbox als container untereinander logischerweise
hast ja nicht mal bei den hostkernel oder irgendwelche hostressourcen die du sharest
wenn es nicht explizit weiterleidest
ein komplett eigenes system was virtualisiert gebootet wird zb wenn man
zum beispiel wenn du in der vm genau genau vorallem brauchen auch länger bis
sie gestartet sind ja ja ist zwar wenn es nicht ignoring das ist eine kleine
form bis oder auch diese Unfortunately started will start fast fast sandbox
das geht schon schnell das bietet auch glaube ich teilweise gut gemacht unter
der sekunde stehe aber trotzdem ja das ist langsamer weil weil ein container es
einfach nur, wir starten einen Prozess. Fertig
aus. Was anderes ist es nicht. Container muss nicht
booten. Eine VM muss booten.
Nein, Container ersetzen niemals
VMs und VMs werden auch nicht wieder Container
ersetzen. Das sind zwei Technologien, die sind beide
super und beide auf
ihre Arten sinnvoll.
Aber laufen Container nicht einem
eigenen Host-System? Nein.
Ja.
Korrekt. Das ist so. Deswegen ist
das Wort Container ein bisschen blöd, weil bei
Container denkt man immer so an Box und
quasi an Lightweight-VM. Was
es nicht ist. Box in Form von
Sandbox trifft es, aber nicht Container
in Form von eigenem System. Ein Container
bootet nicht.
Ein Container startet quasi
nur einen Prozess.
Im besten Fall. Man kann natürlich ein
Script starten, was dann weitere Prozesse startet.
Aber ein Container bootet nicht. Deswegen probieren wir
SystemD-Geschichten in einem Container
zu machen. Das klappt nicht. Das geht
mit sehr viel Hängen und Würgen und mit was
anderem als Docker, aber
in der Regel funktioniert das nicht.
Das ist genauso, wie du es schreibst.
Du kannst ein Alpine-Image in Docker
verwenden, aber trotzdem benutzt du den
Kernel vom Host. Genauso ist es.
Was du von Alpine verwendest,
sind die Libraries, die User-Tools,
alle möglichen Sachen, die ganzen
zusätzlichen Sachen, die
zu so einem Betriebssystem gehören.
Die kannst du aus dem Container-Image benutzen,
aber der Kernel, der ist vom
Host-Betriebssystem. Und auch
manche Ressourcen drumherum sind vom
Host-Betriebssystem. Deswegen kannst du auch in einem Container
nicht einfach sagen, ich lade
und entlade jetzt Kernel-Module, was
du in einer VM machen kannst.
In einer VM kannst
du, nur nochmal, um das zu verdeutlichen,
in einer VM kannst du
Kernel-Module laden und anladen,
ohne dass du Root
bist auf deinem Host-Betriebssystem.
Also du musst nicht Root sein auf dem
Host-Betriebssystem, wo du die VM startest und du hast
trotzdem Root-Rechte in der VM,
weil es ein komplett eigenes
System ist. Also sofern
dir dein System
erlaubt, VMs zu starten.
Ja, aber
genau so ist es, ja.
Das kannst du machen, ja.
Also die sinnvollere Variante wäre
wahrscheinlich
zu gucken, also nur
generell, ja, ob man das in dem Fall
tatsächlich nicht vielleicht wirklich als Container-Workload
irgendwo laufen lassen kann.
Und auf der anderen Seite,
ganz aus ist immer blöd.
Skalierung
ist schön, wenn du so
eine Grundlast abkannst.
Und halt hochskalieren kannst, wenn es notwendig
wird. Ganz aus ist immer blöd, weil
dann müsste der erste User warten und kriegt
Timeouts und muss auf Boot warten und sonst was
in der Richtung. Deswegen kannst du zum Beispiel
sagen, ich habe immer eine Instanz
laufen, aber wenn es viele User
werden, kann ich hochskalieren auf zwölf Instanzen.
Für welchen Zweck macht man sowas?
Auf was bezieht sich sowas?
Container?
Was interessant ist, ist WebAssembly.
Können Motule austauschen? Oh!
Da gibt es ein schönes Beispiel
für. Äh,
Moment.
Da gibt es ein schönes Beispiel für.
Nervt euch das?
Könnte es sein, dass euch das nervt?
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob das
nervt.
Also,
es gibt so ein paar nervige Sachen,
wie zum Beispiel
PC-Speaker.
Und
die Holzhammer-Methode ist,
einfach das Kernel-Modul
zu entladen,
für den PC-Speaker.
Und dann kann ich noch so viel die Tasse drücken,
dann ist es weg. Also, das ist zum Beispiel
ein Grund, warum man vielleicht
Kernel-Module entladen will.
Ist jetzt ein bisschen konstruierter
Grund, ja, gebe ich zu, aber
es ist ein sehr praktischer Grund, weil ich das selbst ab und zu schon hätte.
Gut, das kannst du natürlich vergessen.
Kannst du nicht machen. Also,
PC-Speaker-Unloaden ist nicht in Docker-Containern.
Ja, ja, das gibt es, das gibt es.
Aber das ist meistens keine gute Idee, auf Null
zu skalieren.
Es ist immer gut, wenn du mindestens eine Instanz
laufen hast, dass eben, wenn mal einer drauf geht,
der keine Timeouts bekommt oder irgendwie
aufs Booten warten muss oder sowas
in der Richtung. Deswegen.
Also, ich würde runterskalieren
auf 1 und dann, wenn viel ist, hochskalieren
nach Möglichkeiten.
Was du ja auch machen kannst, ist, du kannst ja vertikales
und horizontales Skalieren irgendwie
kombinieren
mit fetteren Nodes
eventuell. Tja, muss bloß
man sich angucken. Ja, gut,
kommt auf den Anwendungsfall.
PC-Speaker-Unloaden, das ist aber auch die Holzhammer-Methode.
Es gibt noch mehr Methoden.
Du kannst in deiner Input-RC, glaube ich,
irgendwelche Terminal-Sachen ausschalten.
Und es gibt ein paar, es gibt ein paar Methoden.
Aber wenn du die ultimative Holzhammer-Methode
haben willst, um das Gepiepe auszuschalten,
PC-Speaker-Kernel-Modul unloaden.
So, also soviel zu dem Thema.
Manchmal bringt es ein Container halt nicht zum Testen.
Das ist das, worauf ich raus wollte.
Und dann braucht man eine VM und dann kann man
ein Tool hierfür verwenden, wenn man schnell lokale
Test-VMs braucht. Da kann man nämlich
hingehen und sagen
VM-Champ, Run
und dann zum Beispiel
Qt-Chat.
Bam. Und was passiert jetzt?
Er lädt sich ein aktuelles DBN-11
Cloud-Image runter
und er startet im Hintergrund eine VM
und verbindet sich danach per SSH
drauf. Ich zeige euch, dass es
funktioniert. Man braucht den Wirt-Manager nicht.
Ich zeige euch nur nebenbei, dass es funktioniert.
Der hat eine neue VM angelegt, bootet eine neue
VM und
der ist so in
ja, so 20 Sekunden oder so, würde ich sagen,
ist er
fertig ungefähr. Wenn er fertig ist,
lockt er sich per SSH ein.
Zack. Und schon habe ich
meine VM am Start. Das ist der mir
bekannte, schnellste, also
der mir am schnellsten bekannte Weg,
sich lokal eine Test-VM
hinzustellen.
Und ich habe das Tool ja auch gebaut,
weil ich eben öfters den Fall habe,
ich möchte lokale Test-VMs
haben für manche Sachen, zum Beispiel
Unit-Files,
Unit-Systemd-Unit-Files,
irgendwas in der Richtung, irgendwas ausprobieren,
was halt im Container nicht gescheit geht.
Sei es beispielsweise auch mal
per Kommandozeile drauf,
irgendwie
Upt-Install, hast du nicht gesehen,
was ein Systemd-Service hat, was sich
starten lässt, was halt auch im Container
wegen fehlendem Systemd nicht geht, dann müsstest du
eine andere Containerisierungslösung nehmen.
Dann lieber einfach eine VM. Willst du
Tunerscale mit Kubernetes kombinieren? Das habe ich
bis jetzt noch nicht vor. Ich will es mir erstmal angucken.
Hetzner hat
keine Serverless-Funktionalität
aktuell. Also keine, weder
Container-Runtimes, noch
noch Functions,
noch sonst was. Du kannst dir
Es gibt ein ganz
cooles Projekt, falls du Bock auf Kubernetes hast.
Das ist nicht das, was
ich meine. Es hat zwar viele Sterne, aber das meine
ich nicht.
Nicht K8S,
K3S.
Lass da mal.
Das installiert
ein leichtgewichtiges
Kubernetes-Cluster auf Hetzner-VMs.
Wenn du da Bock drauf hast, kann man
sich das geben, aber ansonsten
für reinen Container-Workload ist
das, nee, das ist
Nintendo-Musik.
Du brauchst immer VMs, denn du brauchst für
Kubernetes immer, wenn du es selbst betreiben willst,
immer Nodes, einzelne Nodes. Und die Nodes
sind VMs, zumindest zu
99% der Fälle,
außer lokale Docker-Test-Nodes.
Immer VMs.
Wenn du dir einen Google
Kubernetes-Cluster kaufst,
sind es auch VMs unten drunter.
Wenn du einen Google-Autopilot-Kubernetes-Cluster
kaufst, dann auch, nur dass du dich nicht
selbst drum kümmern musst.
Ja, ist halt die Frage, was man selbst
bauen möchte. Ja, Hetzner ist halt
günstig. Du bist
wahrscheinlich mit Hetzner-VMs
billiger als mit
einem Kubernetes-Cluster, beziehungsweise
in der Gutserver, das kommt drauf an, wie viel du benutzt.
Wenn du dir einen Managed-Kubernetes-Cluster kaufst,
der kostet, ich glaube, die kleinste, der glaubt,
der kleinste Managed-Kubernetes-Cluster kostet bei
Google Cloud irgendwie 75 Euro im Monat oder
sowas. Kannst du
DigitalOcean gehen, da ist es ein bisschen
billiger.
Aber das, weiß ich nicht, ob das
so sinnig ist.
DigitalOcean ist auf jeden Fall ein bisschen
günstiger.
Ja, guck, Kubernetes ist tatsächlich
im Vergleich zu Google relativ günstig.
Da hast du für den Basic-Node, hast du plus
12 Dollar im Monat für den Basic-Node.
Das ist natürlich unschlagbar.
Versus
größere Cloud-Anbieter.
Also, normale
VMs sind bei Hetzner günstig und
die reichen ja auch für alles. Wenn du nichts
Großes hast, was jetzt
so krass vom Skalieren da irgendwie
profitiert und sich auch gut containerisieren
lässt, ist auch eine VM immer noch eine
gangbare Lösung für 1, 2 Services,
die man anbieten muss.
Hast du schon mal Midnight-Commander benutzt? Ja, sicherlich.
Aber gehört nicht zu meinem Standard-Workflow.
So, und
zumindest, ihr habt gesehen, ich habe eine VM erstellt,
total easy, zackig, ja, lokale Test-VM.
Jetzt direkt per SSH connected.
Jetzt kann ich noch, kann ich noch ein paar weitere Sachen machen.
Ich kann mir auflisten lassen.
Oh, ich habe, ich habe noch alte VMs übrig,
übrig, übrig, übrig gebliebene VMs vom letzten Mal.
Guck mal, und wenn man Reste hat, kann man sogar mit VM-Champ clean
einfach alles aufräumen.
Und jetzt ist alles weg.
Jetzt mache ich nochmal Run neue VM.
Da hat man schon gesehen, hier, neue, neue Status-Anzeige hat man gesehen.
Man hat, ähm, gesehen, dass die IP ab ist und pinkt.
Passt nämlich mal auf, passt nämlich mal auf, VM-Champ list.
Jetzt seht ihr die neue, die VM ist running, aber die hat noch keine IP.
Und wenn wir Glück haben, sehen wir auch schnell die IP und dass er noch nicht pinkt.
Wobei ich kann das ganz einfach simulieren.
Überhaupt kein Problem.
Ah, nee, haben wir nicht gesehen.
Okay.
Jetzt ist die VM, es ist, es ist up, up and running.
Was ich jetzt, was ich jetzt mal machen kann, ist, dass man sieht, dass mein neuer,
mein neuer Output mal, if down, falls es noch funktioniert, überhaupt unter Debian 1.0.
So.
Jetzt werdet ihr feststellen, ho, guck mal da, der hatte mal eine IP, der hatte, ups,
was habe ich denn hier, der hatte mal eine IP, aber irgendwie ist es weg.
Also, der macht jetzt bei einem List auch noch, also, der macht jetzt bei einem List auch noch,
der macht jetzt noch ein Check, ob die VM lebt, dahinter.
Bei HomeNetWatch können wir auch machen, ja.
Gucken, jetzt hat er auch festgestellt, oh, guck mal, es ist dead.
Das ist jetzt neu.
Wenn man eine VM löschen will, eine lokale, kann man das so machen, wohlgemerkt alles
mit Autocomplete dabei.
Alles, alles, alles mit Shell, mit Shell Autocomplete hier.
So, das lokale VM weg.
Ja, das ist, das ist ein neues Feature.
Ja.
Ich bin blöd, ich habe mein Terminal noch nicht geupdatet, dass ich einzelne Paints killen
kann.
So, das ist jetzt neu in Version 2 dazugekommen, dass man die, dass man ordentliche List, List
Output hat.
Minus, minus Local Image, das geht auch.
Hat das jemand gefragt?
Ja, du kannst auch, du kannst auch ein lokales Image verwenden, das sieht dann, das sieht
dann, das sieht dann so aus, wenn du lokales Image hast, was du starten willst, kannst
das, kannst das so machen.
Was für IPs bekommen die VMs?
Ja.
Die vom Default, Default Interface, also wenn du ein Default Interface hast, was KVM eigentlich
beziehungsweise QEMO standardmäßig anlegt, dann kriegen die sie hiervon, hiervon IPs.
So, dann gibt es jetzt noch neu die Möglichkeit, wir starten mal wieder die VM, ach ja, der
cached übrigens auch lokal das Image, also ich müsste es nur einmal runterladen.
Neues, ein weiteres neues Feature ist, es gibt jetzt mehr Betriebssysteme, wir haben
jetzt neben Ubuntu und Debian zur Auswahl Arch, by the way.
Fedora 36, Fedora 37, CentOS 7 und einmal Linux 8 und 9 haben wir jetzt noch drinne,
falls da irgendjemand Bock drauf hat und die braucht, kann ja sein.
Ich persönlich werde wahrscheinlich zum Testen immer bei Debian bleiben, aber möglich.
Gerade Arch Linux ist schon mal nicht schlecht zum Testen, falls man irgendwelche Packages
bauen will oder sowas vielleicht, wobei man das auch im Container machen kann.
Mobuntu, das bringt ja in dem Fall nichts, es ist ja, es ist ja nicht UI.
Ja.
Access da drauf.
Könnte man das einstellen, das, das Erstellen der VM beschleunigen?
Ne, das Erstellen der VM dauert doch nur ein paar Sekunden, guck mal.
Du sagst Run, bam, und schon ist die VM erstellt, fertig.
Die VM läuft jetzt.
Das Einzige, was der noch ein bisschen braucht, ist das Booten der VM und das Holen per DHCP.
Also, da wirst du nicht viel dran machen können.
Die VM muss nach wie vor booten.
Und sie muss sich per DHCP eine IP holen, also, da kannst du, da kannst du nichts machen.
So, also, ähm, das ist jetzt auch neu, dass jetzt mehr, mehr Images drin sind.
Windows Images, Windows Images, man könnte mal theoretisch einbauen, bringt aber nichts,
weil du dich da nicht per SSH drauf verbinden kannst.
So, das ist jetzt neu.
Was, was auch neu ist, wenn man sich, man kann sich jetzt den, den Status anzeigen lassen,
wie, wie voll, wie, wie voll die Festplatte ist.
Von der VM.
Also verbinden wir uns mal per SSH, der merkt sich nämlich auch die VMs und man kann sich
per SSH drauf verbinden.
Ja, machen wir sowas mal hier wie, äh, CardDev, wir machen's, wir machen's wie die coolen
Leute, wir machen's wie die coolen Leute, ähm, Image Bin von DevZero.
So, wir schreiben jetzt, wir schreiben jetzt die Festplatte voll, Alter, ich weiß es nicht.
So, wir schreiben jetzt die Festplatte voll und ihr werdet feststellen.
Monk.
KS.
Minus, minus, Color.
Und ihr werdet feststellen, wir machen jetzt mal Update 0.1, ihr werdet feststellen, es
wird jetzt auf einmal ganz schön voll hier.
Also der erkennt on the fly, wenn, der, der, der kriegt jetzt mit, wenn eine VM voll läuft.
Ist das einmal 9, dann 8, der Image.
Ups, hab ich mich da vielleicht vertan?
Und jetzt löschen wir die VM.
Hab ich mich da vielleicht vertan?
Kann sein.
Oh, ja.
Ist es.
Ja.
Auf geht's.
Pull Request Chat.
Da hab ich mich vertan anscheinend, ja.
Ja, das ist ein 8er Image.
So, also das ist, das ist auch neu, dass er das hier jetzt überwachen kann.
Weiteres, weiteres neues cooles, ich muss unbedingt das Killen von Pains in mein Terminal einbauen,
sonst dreh ich durch.
Ich hab's schon eingebaut, aber ich hab die Confit nicht gepusht.
So, ähm, weiteres, weiteres neues Feature, was auch sehr praktisch ist.
Man kann jetzt.
Zum Beispiel sagen, Run für neue VM.
Und wenn man jetzt mal guckt, hier läuft ja noch die Qt, die Qt Chat VM.
Qt Chat 1 läuft ja noch.
Läuft ja noch.
Angenommen, ich möchte die jetzt überschreiben, da kann ich jetzt einfach sagen Run Qt Chat
und dann sagt er mir, Moment, Moment, Moment, die VM gibt es doch schon.
Willst du die löschen und neu erstellen?
Dann kann ich sagen, yep, will ich und Enter drücken.
Aber wir machen mal Nein.
Wir sagen mal Nein und ich zeige euch noch was anderes, was jetzt geht, was auch ganz
praktisch ist.
Minus, minus, ähm, cmd kann man jetzt angeben.
Und da kann ich jetzt zum Beispiel noch übergeben, Moment, nachdem die VM aufgebaut ist, mach
doch mal bitte ein Update minus y.
Und danach ein Echo 1, äh, Echo 1 oder Echo, Echo keckel nach root kec w txt.
So, und jetzt kann man das ausführen.
Dann sagt er, okay, Moment, was ist da los?
Die VM gibt es ja schon.
Wir überschreiben die VM und jetzt werdet ihr gleich feststellen, wenn wir uns da verbunden
haben, per SSH drauf, wir sind schon eine Stunde am Schwätzen, wir haben uns noch nicht
mal TrueNAS angeguckt.
Egal, ich habe Zeit.
Solange heute nicht MMO Kreiselgrind ist, habe ich Zeit.
Bis jetzt hat auch keiner was geschrieben im Discord.
Dann habe ich Zeit bis 22 Uhr.
Kein Ding.
So.
Und wenn die VM dann oben ist, was ein bisschen dauern kann, weil er macht jetzt ja ein Update,
äh, und alles mögliche im Hintergrund.
So.
Und jetzt bin ich drauf.
Und jetzt werdet ihr feststellen, jetzt wurde hier in root eine Datei kec w angelegt.
Das ist das, was ich als Custom Command reingestanden habe.
Und ich kann auch direkt install machen, ohne dass ich update machen muss, weil update wurde
schon gemacht.
Also man kann jetzt auch zusätzliche Kommandos ausführen lassen, direkt nach dem Startup.
Kann man das auch programmieren, dass der automatisch minus minus Color übergibt?
Ja, Moment, das hat ja mit meinem Programm nichts zu tun.
Du meinst das hier, gell?
Das kannst du machen.
Du kannst ein Alias anlegen.
Also wenn du keinen Bock, also mal angenommen, mal angenommen, du hast keinen Bock, jedes
Mal watch minus 0,2 minus minus Color zu schreiben, kannst du einfach sagen alias watch gleich.
Und sobald du das dann verwendest, wirst du feststellen, es funktioniert.
Kannst einfach ein Alias anlegen.
Das ist ein guter Alias.
Wisst ihr was?
Das sind, das ist ein nicer Alias.
Das machen wir doch mal.
Tatsächlich.
Tatsächlich, der erscheint mir ganz praktisch zu sein.
So, jetzt kannst du es ausführen und es funktioniert weiter.
So, ich glaube, ich glaube, das war's.
Das war's an neuen Features.
Ach ne, Moment.
Das, das, das, das, das, eines der praktischsten Sachen habe ich euch ja noch gar nicht gezeigt.
So, guckt, hier ist die VM.
Weil das so schnell geht, weil das so schnell geht, schiebe ich die mal rüber auf den anderen Desktop.
Also hier seht ihr die grafische Oberfläche.
Also ne, das ist das.
Terminal-Ausgabe von der VM halt in, in Wirt Manager.
Den braucht ihr normalerweise nicht, aber ich zeig's hier mal da drüber.
Ihr könnt jetzt sagen, VM-Champ, Reboot oder Reset, je nachdem was ihr wollt.
Oder Restart, worauf ihr Bock habt.
Restart Qt-Chat-VM und bam, die VM wird neu gestartet.
Das ist jetzt, das habe ich auch eingebaut, weil da haben einige danach gefragt, kann man den Kram nicht irgendwie resetten automatisch?
Oder kann man den Kram nicht per Kommandozeile resetten, wenn er irgendwie gecrashed ist oder abgekackt ist?
Ja.
Ja, so sieht's aus.
So, ich glaube, das war's jetzt an neuen Features.
Ja, das muss ich euch nicht zeigen.
Man kann jetzt minus minus Cores angeben.
Ja.
Kann ich, komm, wir machen einfach ne, wir machen einfach ne zweite, wir machen einfach ne zweite VM.
Äh, minus minus CPU, äh, drei CPU-Kerne kann ich da jetzt angeben.
So, und jetzt erstellt er, jetzt erstellt er ne VM mit drei CPU-Kernen.
Wenn ich das haben will, das funktioniert.
Ansonsten war's das.
VM-Champ Version 2 am Start seit zwei Stunden.
Also wer Bock hat, mal auszuprobieren, kann das gerne machen.
Wer irgendwie da Muße verspürt, auch wenn's nur was Kleines ist, wie die Images, ja, wo ich mich verschrieben hab zu fixen, kann gerne nen Issue beziehungsweise nen Pull-Request aufmachen.
Dann merge ich das, dann habt ihr ein bisschen Aktivität in eurem GitHub-Profil und auch ein paar Projekte, die ihr verlinken könnt.
Auch wenn das Projekt nicht wirklich irgendwie relevant ist.
Gut.
Und jetzt guckt hier, Endproc, und jetzt hat er ne VM mit drei CPU-Kernen.
Was man auch sieht mit VM-Champ List, dass das Ding drei CPU-Kerne hat.
Und man kann sich nach wie vor drauf verbinden.
So.
Stern, sehr gut, exzellent.
Alias watch command, echt?
Muss man das machen, warum?
Der ist eigentlich schlau genug zu checken, dass das Kommando, was man intern verwendet, nicht das Kommando ist, was man außen definiert.
Zumindest Zedders H ist schlau.
Zumindest Zedders H ist schlau genug.
Bei anderen Shells bin ich mir da nicht so sicher.
So.
Und jetzt noch ein nicer Touch bei der ganzen Sache.
Ich hab jetzt hier zwei VMs erstellt.
Bin fertig mit testen.
Und ich will einfach alles weggeschmissen haben.
Alle Images, die ich mir runtergeladen hab, alle VMs.
Dann sag ich einfach clean.
Oder...
Hab ich noch ein Alias für clean?
Ich glaube nicht.
Äh, ne. Gibt es nicht.
Ich mach einfach vmchamp clean.
Er löscht alle, er löscht zwei VMs, er löscht Images.
Bam.
Weg.
Und ihr seht, alles clean.
Und die Images sind auch alle weg.
Kannst du dich auch schnell in einer VM ausprobieren?
Ne, muss ich nicht in einer VM ausprobieren.
Weil ich...
Weil ich schon auf meinem Host-System laufen hab und es forkbombt sich hier nix.
Anscheinend, vielleicht...
Vielleicht macht es Zedders H anders.
Wir können es auch gerne mal...
Wir können es auch gerne mal in Bash probieren.
Dafür machen wir tatsächlich mal eine VM auf, weil ich keinen Bock hab, dass mein Host-System abkackt.
Was ist denn eigentlich eine forkbomb?
Ein Programm, was sich mehrfach selbst neu startet.
Also was sich nicht neu startet, selbst aufruft.
Mehrfach selbst neu aufruft.
Du hast dann einen Einstiegspunkt, der dann wieder sich selbst aufruft und dann hast du...
Ja, das ist ein Beispiel für eine forkbomb.
Das sollte man übrigens...
Wir können es gleich mal in einer VM ausführen.
Wir können es gleich mal in einer VM ausführen, dann zeige ich euch das.
Ich kann euch übrigens auch mal kurz erklären, was das hier eigentlich bedeutet.
Ist eigentlich, wenn man die Syntax, die Shell-Syntax verstanden hat, relativ easy.
Machen wir mal.
So, jetzt sind wir in einer VM.
Ich mach hier unten mal CPU-Auslastung auf.
Also als erstes machen wir das mal mit dem Alias.
Weil das kann ich mir auch nicht vorstellen.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass Bash da Probleme hat in der Richtung.
What?
Watch, LS...
Also Bash hat damit auch keine Probleme sich hier irgendwie zu forkbomben.
Ne.
So, und jetzt kann ich euch einmal die original forkbomb zeigen.
Ach Quatsch.
Und ihr werdet feststellen...
Die VM ist freezed.
Die macht gar nichts mehr.
Und mein QEMU braucht einfach 100% CPU-Auslastung.
Ja.
Zwei CPU-Kerne.
Also mein QEMU ist RIP.
Ihr seht übrigens jetzt auch an der Stelle, dass mit dem Ping funktioniert.
Manchmal pingt es noch.
Aber jetzt ist es komplett im Arsch.
Okay, abgekackt.
Und jetzt können wir übrigens das Reboot-Feature verwenden.
Weil es ist ja abgekackt.
Reboot QChat 2.
Und jetzt können wir warten, bis es da oben...
Vielleicht, wenn wir Glück haben, wieder geht.
Wir können ihm auch beim Booten zugucken.
Ja, er bootet.
Er ist demnächst da.
So, und jetzt kann ich euch mal nebenbei erklären, was das Ganze macht.
Also...
Ähm...
Okay, ich glaube, es ist wieder da.
VM-Champ.
SSH.
Und wir sind wieder da.
Okay, ich versuche euch mal zu erklären, was das Ganze macht.
Und zwar...
Wir kopieren das mal in...
Wobei, in der VM ist es ja egal.
Also, folgendes.
Also, warum das funktioniert.
Das ist eine sogenannte Forkbomb.
Weil die sich mehrfach...
Immer wieder selbst aufruft.
Das hier ist eine Funktionsdefinition in Bash.
In Bash definiert man Funktionen so zum Beispiel.
Bla...
Blub.
Und das ist eine Funktion.
Ja, guckt hier.
Echo 1.
Und wenn ich jetzt Blub aufrufe, macht er immer Echo 1.
Sieht man das in der Tabelle, wenn die crasht?
Ja, dann wird die IP rot.
Dann respawntet sie nicht mehr.
So.
Also, das ist eine Funktionsdefinition in Bash.
Man kann das auch irgendwie so machen.
Macht aber keiner.
Das heißt, was man hier sieht, ist eine Funktionsdefinition in Bash.
Und zwar definiert man hier eine Funktion, die einfach Punkt-Doppelpunkt heißt.
Also das, was bei mir Blub heißt, ist in dem Fall ein Doppelpunkt.
Doppelpunkt ist der Funktionsname.
So, und in den Klammern ist der Body der Funktion.
Also das hier, was bei mir Echo 1 ist.
Das heißt, wir definieren eine Funktion, die den Namen Doppelpunkt hat.
Und die ruft sich selber, Doppelpunkt, wieder auf.
Und nochmal sich selber.
Im Hintergrund.
Also die ruft sich zweimal, die ruft sich zweimal selbst auf.
Und packt diesen wieder aufgerufenen Prozess in den Hintergrund.
Das ist wichtig, weil ansonsten wird es ja an der Stelle hängen, bis es beendet ist.
So.
Das heißt, hier ruft sich das zweifach wieder auf.
Es geht zumindest schneller so.
Hier ruft sich das zweimal auf, schickt es in den Hintergrund.
Und das hier ist einfach nur das Ende der Funktionsdefinition.
Also ich könnte, ich hätte auch sowas machen können.
Wird auch funktionieren.
Das ist das Ende der Funktionsdefinition.
Und der abschließende Doppelpunkt dient dazu, das ganze Initial einmal aufzurufen.
Also das hier ruft die hier definierte Funktion auf.
Die ruft sich dann intern zweimal selbst auf und schickt es in den Hintergrund.
Und deswegen läuft dann alles mögliche voll auf dem System, wo du das ausführst.
Von irgendwann Speicher, von Prozesse, Tabellen und alles mögliche.
Das explodiert komplett und das System ist nicht mehr benutzbar.
Weil sie nicht mehr funktionieren.
Weil du versuchst unendlich viele Funktionen aufzuholen.
Das kann man mit Ulimit beschränken.
Mit Ulimit kann man angeben, was manche Prozesse, also was neu gestartete Prozesse machen dürfen.
Und was halt nicht.
So und man kann zum Beispiel jetzt, wenn man sagt Ulimit minus 10.
Ulimit minus C?
Ne, minus U?
Oh, ich weiß es gar nicht aus dem Kopf.
Ich glaube Minus, ich glaube es ist Minus.
Ich glaube es ist Minus U.
Wollen wir kurz nachgucken.
Ja, Minus U.
Du kannst jetzt zum Beispiel also Ulimit minus 100.
Und dann können wir die Forkbombe aufrufen nochmal.
Und wenn wir Glück haben, ist das Limit genug, dass es nicht abkackt.
Ja, siehste.
Bash, Fork, Retry, Resource, Temporary, Unavailable.
Jetzt, jetzt geht das System nicht kaputt.
Weil wir limitiert haben.
Wie viele Prozesse da gestartet werden dürfen.
Er kackt natürlich auch ein bisschen ab, aber er läuft ja immer noch.
Ja, so sieht es aus.
So, und jetzt kommen wir mal zu Trunas.
Wird Zeit.
Eine Stunde 15 geschwätzt, gut ist.
Also, wer mal ein Tool ausprobieren will, kann das machen.
Es gibt ein Arch User Repo.
Ist aber nicht von mir.
Gleich, gleich.
Meins, meins kommt die Tage erst.
Es gibt ein Arch User Repo.
Vom Wort je.
Das baut, das benutzt nicht das Binary, das baut selbst aus dem Master.
Kann man aber auch da drüber benutzen.
Ansonsten.
Releases und das Binary runterladen.
Oder selbst bauen mit .NET Build.
Geht beides.
Ups.
Den wollte ich.
Den wollte ich jetzt nicht anklicken, den Dude.
Alles klar.
So, jetzt gucken wir uns mal Trunas, Trunas Scale an.
Ich muss jetzt mal erklären, warum ich mir das überhaupt angucken will.
Und zwar Hyper Converged Storage Scales Up and Out.
Alter, welche Business, High IQ Business Menschen haben denn da wieder dran gesessen?
Open Hyper Convergent Storage Scales Up and Out.
Was darf man sich da als Normalsterblicher eigentlich drunter vorstellen?
Ja, Storage.
Das ist auch das einzige, was ich verstehe.
Genau, Storage.
Storage.
Gut, mit Open kann man sich noch was vorstellen, mit Scalen irgendwie auch.
Aber das Hyper Convergent, das ist auch so ein neues Buzzword, worauf sie stehen so die
letzten 1, 2 Jahre.
Ja.
Also der Grund, warum ich mir das angucken will, ist folgendes.
Ich bin, also aktuell habe ich bei mir lokal Unraid im Einsatz.
Auch wenn ich Unraid lange Trash Talkt habe, habe ich es jetzt mittlerweile doch im Einsatz,
weil ich eigentlich eine ganz gute Kombination fand aus ganz gutem Web UI für Shares einrichten
und sonst was.
Die Plugin-Funktionalität beziehungsweise die App-Funktionalität ist ganz nice, auch
wenn das meiste Community angepasst wird.
Aber du musst dir um manche Sachen keine Gedanken machen.
Du kannst VMs drauflaufen lassen, du kannst Docker-Container mit einem halbwegs hübschen
Interface drauflaufen lassen, ohne dass du dich um irgendwelche Docker-Compose-Yummels
oder so kümmern musst.
Das fand ich als Kombination für Unraid eigentlich ganz nice.
Wobei ich sagen muss, so richtig hundertprozentig glücklich bin ich mit Unraid nicht.
Die brauchen mir manchmal ein bisschen mehr.
Die brauchen mir manchmal ein bisschen lang Probleme zu fixen.
Es gab letztens ein Problem, dass Docker-Container sich nicht richtig haben updaten lassen.
Da haben sie irgendwie zwei Monate gebraucht das zu fixen oder ich glaube es ist mittlerweile
gefixt.
Ja, noch mehr so Dinge.
Also dass es zum Beispiel Probleme gibt beim Path-Through von USB-Geräten bei manchen,
wo du irgendwie Trick 17 machen musst.
Da bin ich nicht so hundertprozentig glücklich mit Unraid.
Das könnte...
Das könnte noch ein bisschen besser sein.
Aber es geht immer noch nicht.
Es kann doch nicht sein.
Es kann nicht sein, dass sie drei Monate oder zwei, drei Monate für so einen Scheiß brauchen.
Das ist...
Das ist un...
Un...
Wie soll man sagen?
Kann man nicht händeln.
Aber zwei, drei Tage lasse ich mir ja gefallen.
Aber bei so essentiellen Sachen wie Container updaten, das muss innerhalb von spätestens
einer Woche gefixt sein.
Ist es aber anscheinend nicht.
So.
Also wie gesagt, ich bin nicht so hundertprozentig glücklich mit Unraid.
Proxmox...
Fällt bei mir lokal auch ein bisschen flach, weil das nicht genau so richtig gut meinen
Use Case trifft, den ich hier lokal habe.
Ich habe eine...
Neben ein paar Raspberry Pis und ein paar ESPs.
Also mein Hauptziel ist natürlich daheim, dass ich mich nicht großartig drum kümmern will.
Ich will ja keinen zweiten Job für meine Infrastruktur daheim.
Deswegen habe ich auch kein Kubernetes Cluster oder sonst was daheim.
Und ich habe so ernsthaft schon mal drüber nachgedacht, ob ich mir nicht vielleicht wirklich
ein fertiges NAS kaufen soll.
Aber nachdem ich hier einen wirklich schnellen, wirklich zackigen HP Microserver habe mit
genug Festplatten drin, sonst wäre eigentlich rausgeschmissenes Geld.
So.
Und wie gesagt, Proxmox trifft meinen lokalen Anwendungszweck auch nicht hundertprozentig.
Das erste ist, dass kein Docker Support drin ist.
Ja, du kannst LXC und darin Docker und du hast aber kein gescheites Webinterface dafür.
Es kommt mir nicht mit Portainer.
Portainer mag ich persönlich überhaupt gar nicht.
Ja.
Weiß nicht, wer das verwendet.
Das ist doof, dass es da kein Native Support für gibt.
Und das andere ist, Proxmox ist halt eine reine, sagen wir mal so, Virtualisierungslösung
beziehungsweise LXC Container Lösung.
Ich weiß nicht, welches fertige NAS ich mir kaufen würde.
Da habe ich mich auch nicht mit beschäftigt.
Also wahrscheinlich irgendein Synology Ding.
Und wahrscheinlich ein 10 Gigabit Synology Ding, weil ich mich mittlerweile an 10G gewöhnt habe.
Und auch hier die Hardware daheim für den ganzen Kram habe.
So.
Aber es ist halt, nennen wir es mal eine recht reine Virtualisierungslösung.
Und das ist halt nicht meine Anforderung.
Ich will Netzwerkshares über das Webinterface zusammenklicken können.
Außerdem finde ich den, ist 10G schlimmer als 5G?
Ja, doppelt so schlimm.
Das wollte ich übrigens gar nicht anklicken gerade.
Ich wollte eigentlich das Bild daneben anklicken.
Natürlich.
Das ist doppelt so schlimm wie 5G.
Ist ja logisch.
So.
Docker Compose hatte ich selbst eine ganze Weile lokal.
Ist auch nicht so geil.
Irgendwie.
Ich war damit auch nicht glücklich.
Ich habe ja lange Zeit auch Unraid Trash Talken abgesagt.
Installiert euch einfach einen Debian oder Ubuntu Server lokal.
Und dann haut einen Docker Compose drauf.
Drei, vier Services rein und fertig.
Das zum Beispiel mit meiner selbst installierten Kiste ist halt das VM Management dann wieder doof.
Weil du kein gescheites Webinterface hast.
Dann musst du dann Remote Virtual Manager und sowas verwenden.
Alles, alles irgendwie unterm Strich nicht so toll.
So.
Bei Proxmox kommt noch dazu, warum ich da lokal keinen Bock drauf habe ist.
Achso.
Und noch eine charmante Sache an Unraid ist ihr Ansatz mit Raid.
Das es eben kein ZFS ist.
Sondern im Prinzip.
Asynchrones gespiegeltes Sync.
Asynchron gespiegelter Sync.
Da kannst du halt dementsprechend unterschiedlich große Platten verwenden.
Du kannst auch deine Platten komplett voll machen.
Ohne das es Probleme gibt.
Dafür hast du halt auch nicht den großen Performance Vorteil davon.
Aber die Kombination aus einem SSD Cache.
Und diesem asynchronen Sync von Unraid.
Ist eine ganz charmante Sache für lokale Installationen daheim.
Denn für Enterprise Einsatz ist das nichts.
Aber für daheim ist das durchaus in Ordnung.
Auch das man unterschiedlich große Platten verwenden kann.
Finde ich nicht schlecht.
Und vom Handling her ist es auch nice.
Und.
Doch mittlerweile haben die auch ZFS glaube ich seit der neuesten Version.
Oder nach der.
Oder die nächste Version hat ZFS Support.
ZFS ist auch so ein Ding.
Das würde ich mir zweimal überlegen ob man das haben will.
ZFS hat sehr coole Features.
Wie zum Beispiel die eingebaute Verschlüsselung.
Die sie ja hatten.
Noch vor FreeBSD und sowas.
Also die ZFS und Linux Leuten.
Eingebaute Verschlüsselung.
Mittlerweile in ZFS.
Also das war früher.
Proprietär von Oracle gegeben hat.
Mittlerweile.
Gibt es glaube ich auch das Feature.
Das man.
Pools erweitern.
Nicht Pools wie nennten sich das so.
Rates quasi erweitern kann.
Das dieses Feature ist quasi seit 5 Jahren Testing.
In ZFS und Linux.
Gut aber mit ZFS würde ich mir das trotzdem überlegen.
Weil ZFS bringt.
Tatsächlich einiges.
An Komplexität rein.
Auto Snapshots.
Die ganze Checksum Geschichte.
ZFS ist ne coole Sache.
Und ZFS entgegen.
Der Meinung des.
FreeNAS Forums.
Beziehungsweise des TrueNAS Forums.
Oder wer auch immer das jetzt heute ist.
Braucht man bei ZFS auch nicht.
3 TB RAM.
Um es im Heimbereich.
Ordentlich betreiben zu können.
Da sind ja so Dinger im Umlauf wie.
Mindestens.
Was ist das.
1 GB RAM.
Pro 10 GB Storage.
Oder irgendwie so ganz komisch.
Oder 1 GB pro TB oder sowas in der Richtung.
Ja das kann man.
Das kann man zwar recht easy.
Mit den heutigen aktuellen.
Mit den aktuellen Storage Preisen.
Geht das noch halbwegs.
Aber trotzdem stell dir mal vor.
Da sind ja 13 TB Platten drin.
Da brauchst du mindestens 30 GB RAM.
Aber wozu im Heimbereich.
Und du kannst ZFS ohne Probleme.
Auch mit weniger RAM.
Betreiben.
Dann hast du weniger Caching.
Logischerweise.
Und ja.
Deduplication kannst du vielleicht nicht machen.
Aber mal ganz davon abgesehen.
Das will auch kaum einer.
Und das ist im Heimbereich auch nicht so wild.
Wenn du dann nicht so viel Cachen kannst.
ZFS ist auch ganz gut zu betreiben.
Nach Heim.
Trotzdem würde ich mir tatsächlich überlegen.
Ob man das im Heimbereich haben will.
Ja es hat nice Features.
Aber du musst auf einige Dinge achten.
Du musst zum Beispiel darauf achten.
Dass du ZFS Pools oder Volumes.
Ich bin mir gerade gar nicht sicher aus dem Kopf.
Wie das heißt.
Dass du die glaube ich nie ganz voll machst.
Weil du sonst Probleme hast.
Die wieder darauf zuzugreifen.
Und die überhaupt leer zu bekommen.
Und die nicht mehr als 85% des Speicherplatzes füllen.
Weil ZFS sonst Probleme hat.
Irgendwie Checksummen zu generieren.
Da muss man schon auf ein paar Sachen achten.
Und das nächste ist.
Wo ich mir auch Gedanken machen würde.
Bei ZFS.
Wenn es mal nicht mehr geht.
Wenn es mal irgendwie Probleme gibt.
Das Vergnügen hatte ich schon.
Also dann wartet mal ab.
Bis ihr mit einem Rescue System startet.
Und dann erst mal 15 Minuten googeln müsst.
Wie man genau überhaupt jetzt richtig ordentlich.
Ein ZFS Pool Mountet.
Ja das kann man machen.
Muss man aber auch erst machen.
Und dann muss man erst mal gucken.
Wie mountet man den Pool.
Und was ist denn jetzt das Problem.
Also wenn es nicht geht.
Hat man dann tatsächlich ein bisschen mehr Schmerzen.
Ja schön Leute.
Wenn ihr es aus dem Kopf wisst.
Ist halt die Frage.
Weiß das auch jemand aus dem Kopf.
Der sich das vor 2 Jahren mal eingerichtet hat.
Sonst nie was mit ZFS macht.
Und ihm das nach 2 Jahren kaputt geht.
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Dann wird es eh ganz haarig.
Also auch die Möglichkeiten zum Recovern.
Sind mit ZFS.
Auf jeden Fall ein bisschen schwieriger zu benutzen.
Wenn es mal wirklich kaputt geht.
Man muss sich einfach überlegen.
Ob man das wirklich.
Im Heimbereich benutzen möchte.
Es hat coole Sachen.
Viele von den coolen Sachen.
Sind nice to have im Heimbereich.
Aber jetzt auch nicht so.
So der Game Changer.
Snapshots sind super nice.
Das ist die beste Geschichte im Heimbereich.
Auch keine Frage.
Gerade die Möglichkeit.
Dass man Snapshots über das Netzwerk.
An anderen ZFS Pool schickt.
Ist schon nice.
Snapshots sind cool.
Dass du bei ZFS nie das Problem hast.
Dass deine Festplatten Fehler haben können.
Ohne das du es mitbekommst.
Ist auch nice.
Hat schon ein paar Sachen.
Ob man das im Endeffekt haben will.
Und sich den Overhead.
Gönnen will.
Muss jetzt jeder selbst wissen.
Deswegen bin ich mit Proxmox.
Als reine Virtualisierungsplattform.
Und ZFS bei mir daheim.
Auch nicht so happy.
Zumal ich mit einer reinen Virtualisierungsplattform.
Bei der Sache nicht großartig anfangen kann.
Also im Prinzip.
Ich bin weder mit Unraid so richtig glücklich.
Noch trifft Proxmox so richtig gut.
Mein Use Case daheim.
Deswegen habe ich mir gedacht.
Gucken wir uns doch einfach mal.
Trunas Scale an.
Was früher mal.
FreeBSD.
FreeNAS.
Auf BSD Basis war.
So viel.
Jetzt habe ich es.
Dann laden wir uns das doch mal runter.
Wir machen nicht.
Nested Virtualisierung in Virtualisierung.
Wir machen dann später vielleicht.
Nested Virtualisierung um das VM Feature zu testen.
Aber wir machen nicht.
Nested Nested Nested Virtualisierung.
Deswegen lade ich es hier runter.
Das ist das was früher mal FreeNAS war.
Wie gesagt damals noch auf BSD Basis.
Und soweit ich weiß.
Ist Trunas Scale mittlerweile.
Auf Linux.
Und Trunas Core.
Ist glaube immer noch.
BSD.
Und Enterprise Support und sowas.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber ich glaube Scale ist das was wir haben wollen.
Okay wo gibt es den Download.
Wo ist der Download.
Leute.
Ah.
She baited.
Fast wie bei Ubuntu früher.
Wo du auch dachtest du musst.
Ist das mittlerweile eigentlich besser gemacht.
Die Ubuntu Download Seite.
Ja Moment.
Wenn man hier drauf geht und jetzt auf Free Download klickt.
Okay ja die haben das mittlerweile besser gemacht.
Früher sah es immer so aus.
Als musst du was spenden an Ubuntu.
Was du überhaupt nicht musstest.
Okay Download Current Stable Version.
Dann laden wir es doch mal runter.
Auf BSD Basis.
Auf gehts.
2 Minutes left.
Elementary OS.
Ja wo.
Ja das kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Das haben wir uns im Stream auch mal angeguckt.
Ich muss sagen.
Ich fand Elementary OS tatsächlich eines der wenigen.
Auch wenn es sich für mich nicht gut geeignet hat.
Als tägliche.
Täglich zu benutzen Linux Distribution.
Eine der wenigen.
Linux Distros.
Wenn ich das richtig noch im Hinterkopf habe.
Wo ich auch im Stream gesagt habe.
Das macht irgendwo einen.
Konsistenten und gut durchdachten Eindruck.
Gibt es ja nicht so viele Desktop Distributionen.
Wo man das drüber sagen kann.
Ich weiß das du den Download meinst.
Kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Das sie sich da auch zum Spenden aufgefordert haben.
Also es gab ein paar Distros.
Die fand ich nicht schlecht.
Die würde ich auch jemandem empfehlen.
Der auf irgendwas gut gestyltes setzt.
Also Elementary war eins davon.
So 0815 mäßig.
Kann man Linux Mint sicherlich auch empfehlen.
Vom Design her und vom.
So wie sich.
Insgesamt.
Einheitlich anfühlt.
Was ich auch persönlich nicht schlecht fand.
War dieses China Chinesen Linux.
Ich überlege gerade wie es heißt.
Wisst ihr noch wie das heißt?
Das Deepin.
Deepin Linux genau.
Das fand ich auch ganz cool.
Aber wie gesagt.
Ich würde kein China Chinesen Linux benutzen.
Wie gesagt.
Ich würde eh nichts anderes verwenden.
Als irgendwas Arch Basedes.
Allein schon weil ich da mein i3.
Und mit meiner Custom Config verwenden kann.
Und gut ist.
So Truna Scale.
Nice runtergeladen fertig.
Dann installen wir das mal.
New Virtual Machine Custom.
Workstation 17 ganz toll.
Ja aber wir haben Installer Disk.
Ich installiere das later.
Linux.
Ja sieht gut aus.
Wie viel Platz habe ich noch auf C?
Auf jeden Fall.
Trunas.
Number of Processors.
Number of Cores 5.
Bisschen scheppe Anzahl.
RAM.
32G.
Na komm 16G.
16G RAM.
NAT.
Is.
Bridged.
Next.
Create New Disk.
Wir wollen es nicht splitten.
200G.
Ladde.
Trunas Vmdk Customize.
So der Printer kommt raus.
Und die Soundkarte kommt raus.
USB.
CPU und so.
Das sieht alles gut aus.
Finish.
Dann gucken wir doch mal.
Trunas.
CD.
Image.
Download.
Trunas.
Was piepst denn du rum?
Trunas Installation.
Gut.
Wir skalieren mal horizontal.
So.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Ich habe keine Ahnung von Trunas.
Macht er standardmäßig GPT und UEFI statt BIOS?
Gute Frage.
Ich glaube nicht.
Wir stellen es mal auf
UEFI um.
Hast du Recht.
Power off.
Gucken wir mal wie gut das damit klar kommt.
Ich glaube der macht
standardmäßig immer noch
BIOS Boot.
Wie er piepst.
Vielleicht soll ich das ganze mal ordentlich machen.
Ne nicht Free Stretch.
Keep Aspect.
Ratio.
Ok Installation.
Wo liegt der Unterschied zwischen UEFI und BIOS?
Ich habe keine Ahnung was genau
der Unterschied ist.
Also ich kann dir nur sagen,
dass UEFI die deutlich neuere Geschichte ist.
Die genau unter anderem so Sachen wie
Secure Boot
und mehr
Devices und Maus Support
und sowas im BIOS kann.
Aber
was jetzt ganz genau der Unterschied ist
zwischen allem.
Außer das UEFI neuer komplexer ist und mehr kann.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Warum kann man da
eine alternative Baudreieck auswählen?
Vielleicht für den Fall der Fälle,
dass man das über einen Serial Port installieren möchte.
Warum auch immer
wenn man das machen muss.
Ok Install Upgrade.
Vmware 200 GB Platte.
Sekunde Leute.
Moment mal.
Das ist ja Blödsinn was ich hier mache.
Ich will ja RAID Geschichten testen.
Da müssen noch mehr Platten rein.
So.
Wir machen jetzt noch ein paar Platten.
Sonst kann ich das ja gar nicht ordentlich.
Ne Chat.
Nicht GPT Chat.
Wir machen das anders.
Ne Systemplatte.
Und wenn ich installiert habe,
hänge ich neue Platten rein
und gucke dann mal
was das damit macht.
Ja
dudud.
Das machen wir mal.
Wir installieren jetzt erstmal
und dann konfigurieren wir über das Web Interface
neue Platten.
Kleines System. Ja 200G.
Aber mal abgesehen davon.
Das ist ja eh so ein Growing File System.
This will erase all partitions.
Oh nein.
Äh.
Was?
Web UI Authentification Method.
Administrative User
oder Root User.
Administrative User.
Ok.
Leute Massive Password.
Ich benutze nur
Best Practice Passwörter.
Und das sind natürlich die verbreitetsten.
Ich mein.
Wie verbreitet das Passwort schlecht sein.
Das muss ja schon ein Grund haben warum so viele Leute benutzen.
Create a Swap Partition.
Ja.
Meinetwegen.
Also ich weiß nicht ob Trunas für USB Stick
ausgelegt ist.
Also Unraid ist für USB Stick
ausgelegt.
So viel weiß ich.
Die booten auch ins RAM vom USB Stick.
Also ein bisschen
hübscheren Installer hätten sie auch machen können oder?
Der Installer
ist äußerst nichtssagend.
Macht der überhaupt noch was?
Das ist aber kein BSD mehr.
Krasser Auslastung hat er jetzt nicht.
Ah doch.
Ah da. Da sind wir.
Trunas Installation on SDR Succeeded.
Please reboot and remove
installation media.
Alles klar. Machen wir Reboot System.
Und jetzt müssen wir Installation Media
removen.
Und jetzt rebooten wir nochmal.
Ok. Trunas Scale.
Auf geht's.
Gib ihm.
Ok. Sieht furchtbar advanced aus beim
Booten. Aber sofern er bootet
soll mir das Recht sein.
Ok. Also. Config Network haben wir ja.
Alles klar.
2.1.2.1
Alles klar. Dann machen wir das. Können wir von der VM
aus machen. Von der VM auf die VM.
1.1.2.1.2.1
Zack. UI. Admin.
1.2.3.4.5.6
Safe. Da sind wir.
In unserer Trunas Kiste.
Ok.
Leute. Ich habe, ich habe Trunas eine Weile
verwendet. Ich habe Trunas nicht einmal
angeguckt. Ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung davon jetzt.
Deswegen müssen wir uns das jetzt zusammen
mal anschauen in Ruhe. So.
Erstmal Dark Theme standardmäßig.
Was ich schon mal sehr nice finde.
Status of True Command.
Was ist True Command?
Ach so. Irgendein Cloud Service
von denen. Ne.
Jetzt nicht. Jobs.
Ok. Da sieht man irgendwelche Background Sachen.
Alerts.
Setting. Ich mag.
Ich mag das Web Interface.
Das Web Interface gefällt mir ohne Mist gefällt mir jetzt schon.
Was investierst du?
Ja. Ich habe ein paar Stonks. Ich habe ETFs.
Die sind dieses Jahr allerdings nicht gut gelaufen.
Ich muss sagen.
Ich mag das Web Interface. Das gefällt mir.
Das hat was.
Das ist ein bisschen Material Design
like.
Aber nicht so krass
nervig Material Design like.
Das man
schon keinen Bock mehr drauf hat.
Also bis jetzt im ersten Blick gefällt mir das Web Interface ganz gut.
Check for Updates.
Keine Updates. Ok.
Storage. Was hat er da? Keine Pools.
Logisch. Ich habe ja auch nichts drin.
Create Pool.
Ja gut. Ich habe keine
Devices.
Das funktioniert schon mal nicht.
Dann hängen wir doch mal ein paar Festplatten rein. Mal gucken.
Wenn ich Festplatten reinhänge. Ob der das
on the fly checkt oder nicht.
Hard Disk hinzufügen. Jawohl.
Create New Disk.
Ja machen wir mal.
Wir müssen ja. Oder machen wir mal 32G.
Wir müssen es ja nicht übertreiben jetzt.
Moment. Das ist die falsche VM.
Ja. Ich habe es auch gerade am Namen gesehen.
Dass da irgendwas nicht stimmt.
Ok. Also.
Hängen wir es mal hinzu. Disk.
Create New Disk.
32G.
Single File. TrueNAS.
Perfekt. So. Noch eine.
Network. Network.
Network. Single File.
32G.
Weiter. Weiter.
Ok. Nice. Dann schauen wir mal.
Ob der die jetzt auch automatisch erkennt.
Oder ob man rebooten muss oder sowas.
Das System hat 200G.
Ne. So viel werde ich davon auch nicht verwenden.
So.
Hat der Platten erkannt?
Der hat keine Platten erkannt. Das heißt man muss jetzt auf jeden Fall erstmal sagen.
Neue
Disks
Detecten please.
Ich glaube nicht, dass man dafür
Restarten muss.
Das Problem ist nur. Ich weiß nicht wo der Knopf ist.
Zum Neu Detecten von
angeschlossenen Festplatten.
Muss man wirklich rebooten, wenn man
neue Festplatten angeschlossen hat?
Kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen, dass man da
rebooten muss.
Ok.
TrueNAS.
Detect. Disk.
Any Disks.
Autoscan
for new harddisks.
Im Terminal?
Schau ab in Storage.
Gut. Das ist ja viel. Hier Storage hat man.
Ok. Da ist er nicht drinne.
Könnte sein, dass es daran liegt,
dass ich in der VM bin.
Aber probier mal.
Wie komme ich irgendwie auf ein Terminal hier drauf?
Das wäre auch noch mal interessant. Aha. Shell?
Ah. Excellent. Excellent.
BF.
Was hat man da alles am Start?
Fdisk.
Fdisk kann man da drauf. BLKID.
Wir haben hier gar nichts drauf.
Sudo-i vielleicht. Ok.
Aber BLKID-T.
Och ne. Oh Gott. Wie funktioniert das?
SDA.
Ne. Ne. Ne. Ne. Ne. Ne.
Der hat die schon erkannt.
Ne. Moment. Das ist alles SDA.
Wie ging das? BLKID-Tree?
Ne. LSBLK. LSBLK.
Ah. Das habe ich gesucht.
Ok. Ne. Da hat noch nichts erkannt an
Disks.
Was aber auch klar ist.
Die sind ja nicht formatiert.
Ne. Sieht nicht so aus, als hätte er irgendwelche
irgendwelche neu eingesteckten Disks
erkannt. Also. Dann.
Wobei. Reboot. Ups.
Das Webinterface. Wir müssen ja lernen, wie das funktioniert.
Dashboard. System Settings.
Boot. Vielleicht.
Da. Ah.
Ok. Finde ich gut.
Halbwegs selbsterklärende
Webinterface.
Schon mal ganz nice.
So. Jetzt reboote da.
Ah. Guck mal. Der hat auch so im Hintergrund
so eine Schleife laufen. Gucken, ob es wieder da ist.
Das ist eine gute Idee. Also. Ich muss sagen.
Das Webinterface gefällt mir. Das macht jetzt
einen etwas
moderneren Eindruck, als das von Unraid
zum Beispiel. Wobei das
auch noch geht.
Proxmox habe ich zu wenig Erfahrung, um da was zu zu sagen.
Du du du du.
Du du du du du.
Sieht echt
Pockers aus. Ja. Moment. Wir haben ja noch gar nichts gemacht.
Wir haben uns nur das
Webinterface angeguckt.
Die Optik sollte einer nicht täuschen.
So. Alles klar. Wir haben
5 Cores und laufen auf einem
i7 13900K.
Ja. So halb.
Gut. Die VM denkt das halt.
Ok. Dashboard. Was kann man hier?
Kann man Zeug konfigurieren? Network Gadgets.
Spannend ist
das jetzt nicht.
Gibt es Dashboard Plugins oder sowas?
Ok. Jetzt erstellen
wir mal. Ok. Hier sieht man Netzwerkinterface.
Es ist ganz hübsch gemacht.
Mit was haben die die Graphen gemacht?
Chart.js. Ok.
Also.
Network Interfaces. Blub blub.
Storage. Gucken wir mal. Create Pool.
Da haben wir doch
schon was.
There are two disks available that have non-unique
serial numbers. Non-unique
serial numbers can be used...
Was?
Sollte es nicht normal sein,
dass die... Achso.
Hä?
Ach. Vielleicht haben die unter der Haube
die gleiche Seriennummer.
Moment. SDA und SCC.
Moment. Warum ist SDA jetzt
auf einmal die...
Hast die geklont?
Ich habe die einfach hinzugehängt.
Wir gucken mal, was passiert.
Mal gucken. Wir gucken einfach mal, was passiert.
SDA. Moment. Läuft mein System jetzt auf
SDB oder was?
Ja. Mein System läuft auf SDB.
Das ist natürlich ganz toll.
Die sind virtuell. Ja. Aber ich hätte mal
erwartet, dass die zumindest die Seriennummer...
Egal. Wir machen das jetzt trotzdem.
SDA und SDB.
Was wollen wir machen?
Suggest Layout. Ok. Was sagt der mir da?
Dann Stripe.
Ja gut.
Gibt ja nur zwei zur Auswahl
mit zwei Devices.
Vielleicht sollten wir doch
drei Devices reinhängen.
Weil
du kannst ja im Prinzip nur mirrorn
oder stripen mit zwei Disks.
Was willst du großartig machen?
Also entweder kannst du
beide Disks
quasi zusammenfassen
und den einen Inhalt spiegeln
auf den anderen für Auswahlsicherheit
oder du kannst beide zusammenfassen
und die Daten splitten zwischen beiden
für mehr Speed. Also quasi
Raid 0 vs.
Raid 1.
Wir schalten noch mal kurz aus.
Und ich hänge noch mal eine dritte Platte rein.
Weil ansonsten ist das Ganze ja relativ unsinnig
das auszuprobieren.
Add Disk
32G
Jawoll. Ok. Und noch mal starten.
So. Schauen wir mal
ob das jetzt wieder an Start kommt.
Waiting.
Du hast dir ein Synology NAS gekauft.
Schau eher was...
Doch. Ist ne gute Sache.
Ich find die Dinger gar nicht übel.
Alles was ich bisher gesehen hab davon
kann man durchaus machen
wenn man sich möglichst wenig
damit beschäftigen will
und Preis-Leistung passen
und man mit den Featuren klar kommt.
Ist doch alles gut. Kann man kaufen.
Moment. Ich hab nicht nur hier Tabs.
Ich hab nicht nur hier Tabs.
Und wie hier
hab ich ja kaum Tabs. Das geht aber net.
Hier hab ich noch ein paar.
Aber da muss schon noch ein bisschen was gehen.
Medieninformatiker.
Da müsstest du aber zumindest doch schon mal
Netzwerk-Storage irgendwie aufgesetzt haben, oder?
Paperless.
Kann ich nix zu sagen.
Ich hab lokal jetzt auch nicht so super
viel Zeug. Ich glaub ich hab irgendwie
um 10 Container laufen. Irgendwie
ein Wiki, ne ne ne
ne ne
Sammelding für meine
Hardware-Teile.
Boah, ich weiß aus dem Kopf gar nicht
alles. Was aber auch dafür
spricht, dass es sehr unauffällig und eigentlich gut
läuft. Ja, ich hab
ein Video gemacht, aber da ist nicht alles drin und das
Video ist auch outdated.
Und manche Sachen
davon benutze ich auch gar nicht mehr.
So, also lass mal weiter gucken.
Jetzt können wir mal ein Storage-Pool anlegen.
Create-Pool. Was haben wir zur Auswahl?
So.
A.
Ist das ein B oder ein D?
Dann adden wir das mal hinzu.
Zack.
Also, jetzt haben wir zur Auswahl
Muss man das hier anklicken?
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Z-Rate, Mirror,
Stripe. Okay, wir machen ein Z-Rate.
Logischerweise, sonst wär ja blödsinnig.
Und jetzt brauchen wir ein Name.
CutePool.
Encryption. Ja, das
probieren wir auch mal aus. Das ist ja ein
neues Feature. Neu. Gibt's ein paar Jahre schon.
Neues Feature.
Encryption is used for
user storing when the pool
level 8 does not apply to the storage pool
or disks in the pool. Hä?
Achso, dass man da auch...
Ja, probieren wir das doch mal aus.
Mit Encryption.
Und jetzt? Okay.
Also, er schätzt 60
Gigabyte.
Sorry. Gebi-Byte.
60 Gibi-Byte.
Gebi-Byte?
Gibi-Byte sind's nicht.
Gibi-Byte.
Weil wir haben
3x32G und davon
fällt eine weg, weil es quasi
so ein Rate 5 ist.
ZFS-Rate.
Ist quasi sowas wie ein Rate 5.
So. Create. Guck mal noch mal.
Warning. Will be erased. Ja, alles gut.
Mach.
Was ist Z-Rate? Oh, was?
Losing the ability to
unlock the pool can cost in losing data.
Or passphrase.
Moment, ich konnte überhaupt keine
passphrase eingeben. Warum nicht?
Download Encryption
Key. Achtung, Leute.
Keyleak.
Monks, Keyleak.
Losing the ability to unlock
the pool. Okay, done.
Ich hätte es gerne
tatsächlich in dem Fall sogar mit Passwort
oder irgendwas anderem gelockt, dass ich
anlocken muss beim Reboot.
Weil, wie
anlocke ich
es jetzt?
Testen wir mal Rebooten. Mal gucken, ob er sich jetzt automatisch
mountet nach dem Rebooten.
Das würde mich jetzt
wundern. Aber mal gucken.
Ich meine, wenn er den
Key unencrypted bei sich gespeichert hat,
kannst du es dir doch auch gleich sparen mit dem
Verschlüsseln, oder?
Ja. Muss ich jetzt
beim Booten vielleicht ein Passwort eingeben?
Nö. No Pass.
Muss ich nicht.
Ja, gut. Storage.
Ja, super. Das ist gemountet.
Ja, aber wo ist denn
der Sinn vom Verschlüsseln, wenn das
gemountet ist?
Der Key muss ja dann irgendwie unverschlüsselt auf der Platte
oder so liegen.
Was man kann beim Pool anlegen?
Verschiedene Sachen auswählen. Echt, wo?
Habe ich nicht gesehen. Können wir es nochmal ausprobieren.
Okay, wie löscht man den Pool wieder?
Hier. Export Disconnect.
Destroy
Data on this Pool. Was? Quatsch.
Was macht Destroy Data?
Überschreibt das das dann, oder?
Confirm.
Schauen wir mal. Legen wir den Pool nochmal
neu an. Oh je.
Es hängt.
Okay, es hat funktioniert. Close.
Create Pool. Jetzt aber.
Oh, man kann hier was auswählen.
This disk is part...
Ja, ja. Habe ich. Habe ich.
Alles Backup. Alles Backup. Alles gut Backup.
Ja, ja. Alles Backup.
Rechts vom Namen dann bei Encryption.
Ne, hier kann man keine Passwörter auswählen.
Wo kann man hier Passwörter auswählen?
Ne, die Application wollen wir
auf jeden Fall nicht haben. Ich sehe hier nichts.
Also Chat,
seht ihr hier irgendwie was zum Passwort
angeben?
Also ich nicht.
Also anscheinend doch nachträglich. Okay.
Ja, ja.
Ja, ja. Ich download den Encryption Key wieder.
Okay.
Und jetzt wo? Manage
Manage Disks. Manage
Devices. Was haben wir hier?
Hä?
Ah, da kann man sowas
einstellen wie Spin.
Also ob die Platten sich ausschalten
sollen im Standby und sowas. Okay.
Gut. Gut, dass es das gibt.
Manage Devices. Was haben wir da zu bieten?
Extend.
Da kann man
doch nur gleich große, beziehungsweise
mindestens, mindestens genauso große
dabei hängen.
Hardware Disk Encryption
Drive Info
Nö.
Ein paar Datasets vielleicht gucken.
Encryption.
Es ist
Ah.
Edit.
Hier kann man das umstellen.
Massive Passphrase, Leute.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6. Kommt ihr nie.
No, God.
Please, no. No.
No.
Okay. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
P, B,
K, D, F,
2. Iteration.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, was es ist. Ich vermute
mal, wie oft
der Key quasi
Tja, wie soll man das beschreiben?
Wie oft der Key gehasht wird,
bevor das, was rauskommt,
dann zum Entschlüsseln benutzt wird. Irgendwie sowas
in der Richtung wird es wahrscheinlich sein.
Ja.
Ist sowas in der Richtung, okay.
Ist dafür, um
Brute Force Sachen langsamer zu machen.
Confirm.
Save.
Invalid.
Contains the
System Dataset.
Was?
System?
Mein System ist da nicht drauf?
Ja, mein System ist
ja da gar nicht drauf.
Das ist ein extra
Wie man hier auch sieht,
dass da gar nichts drauf ist.
Achso, this Dataset is used
by the System.
Und das bedeutet jetzt
was?
Was, was, was, was, was
bedeutet das jetzt genau?
This Dataset is used by the System.
Use System
Dataset.
What? Syslog?
Jetzt blick ich schnell mal durch.
Erst unmounten, okay.
Ja, why not?
Export.
Confirm export.
Äh, wir
deleten mal nicht die Configuration.
Oh, wir können die Configuration
ne, wir deleten nicht die
Configuration.
Ja, heute ist Poggers Mod Tag.
Leute, jetzt wo ihr alle da seid, während der Pool löscht,
können wir einmal in den Chat
für unsere Mods, die sich immer sehr viel
Mühe geben und auch sehr viel Mist sich durchlesen
müssen, eine Runde alle
einmal in den Chat bitte Mod Check.
Für unsere
Pog Modgis.
Ja komm, da geht noch ein bisschen
mehr. Gib den Mods mal ne
Runde Mod Check.
Morty, ich hab mir übrigens vorher auch nen Repo
angelegt. Muss ich noch befüllen.
Minus Bin.
Pog Check.
Nicht Mod Check. Pog Check.
Nice.
Sehr schön, Leute. Modgis freuen sich.
Hoffentlich.
Mehr kriegen sie ja hier nicht.
Besten Modgis.
Okay,
No Pools. Kann ich den Kram
jetzt, das geht aber nicht.
Also mit
Unmount und so, ist hier
schon mal nix.
Weil jetzt hier bei Storage und so gar nix
drin steht.
Okay, das ist doof. Darkstar, danke schon
für den Sub. Hast du schon was
mit Octopus? Ich hab das schon mal gehört.
Ja, aber sagt, ne, hab ich nix mitgemacht.
Pool. Cool Pool.
Okay. Also das funktioniert schon mal.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich mir das gedacht hab.
So, System. Wie, was, was will
der? Was will der hier mit
System Pool die ganze Zeit?
Snapshot kann man hier drüber machen?
Okay, ja.
Advanced.
Use Sy... Was? Okay, das muss ich mal...
Was ist das System Dataset?
Das ist nicht...
Das ist anscheinend nicht die Bootplatte.
Jetzt ist er gelockt.
Ey, da ist nix gelockt.
Der ist unlocked, oder?
Jetzt ist er locked.
Unlock.
Ja, choose file.
Choose file zum Unlocken.
Aber,
was ich jetzt nicht checke ist, der hat sich das doch
gemerkt und konnte beim Rebooten selbst
das sich...
Na gut.
Choose file. Das will ich ja so nicht, wenn
später ein Passwort...
Wo ist es denn?
Pool.
Ach, hier kann man das auch
reinpasten. Okay, das ist natürlich
auch nicht schlecht.
Save. Das ist aber
so ganz gut gemacht mit dem Keyfile.
Was ich mich frage
ist, warum er es unlocken kann beim Rebooten.
Aber jetzt beim
Neumounten muss ich es einmal
einhängen.
Komisch. Na gut.
Fetching
Encryption Summary. Ja, dann fetche mal...
Fetch mal hinne.
Was fetcht der denn da?
Und was macht
er da eigentlich so lang?
Habe ich es irgendwie kaputt gemacht?
Ich meine, ich habe nichts gemacht, aber
das dauert mir
verdächtig lange, ehrlich gesagt.
Gehen wir nochmal drauf, hier auf der anderen Seite.
Datasets. Immer noch locked.
Wir gucken mal, ja.
Erst recht, wir schauen mal eine Runde.
Ja...
MD Rate? Ja, das ist wahrscheinlich
für System. Okay, das ist
mir way too high IQ, was da abgeht.
Disk Failure?
Aber SDC ist doch...
Ich kann da gar kein
Disk Failure haben.
SDC, SDC1...
Interessiert ja auch nicht.
Qt Pool ist ja SDC2.
Oder...
Swap. Swap ist
SDC.
Ähm, okay.
Ja, das...
Also, wenn solche Basic-Sachen wie
Einhängen und Aushängen nicht funktionieren, okay.
Das könnte an meinem VM-Setup
liegen.
Man weiß ja nie.
Durchaus möglich, dass es an meinem VM-Setup
liegt. Aber sollte
eigentlich nicht, oder?
Komm, wir rebooten mal.
Wir rebooten mal. Kann ja nix schaden.
Gucken wir mal, was er macht hier.
Naja.
20 Minuten!
Der will's aber wissen, oder?
Wenn er 20
Minuten braucht, um irgendwas zu booten, dann
stimmt aber was nicht.
Okay, er ist wieder da.
Admin. Yep, login.
Login.
Da sind wir wieder. Storage.
Datasets locked. Ja, mal gucken, ob ich's jetzt
unlocken kann. Wahrscheinlich wieder nicht.
Wir machen mal ein neues Tab auf.
Was nicht funktioniert, okay.
Wir machen ein neues Tab auf. Shell.
Und schauen mal, ob da irgendwas...
Bis jetzt noch alles okay.
Hat das mit dem O2-Code geklappt?
Den hab ich nicht verwendet. Ich hab mich neu angemeldet.
Unlock child
encrypted routes, was? Also unlock any
encrypted...
Machen wir mal weg.
Okay, Downloads.
Queue Pool.
Add Datasets.
Save.
Yes.
Jetzt hat's
funktioniert, okay.
Okay, das ging jetzt. Aus irgendwelchen Gründen.
Mit Reboot hat alles funktioniert.
Ich möchte allerdings
trotzdem
die Encryption umstellen.
Aber die Encryption darf ich
nicht umstellen.
Weil System das irgendwie verwendet.
Das, das, also
die Logik
hab ich noch nicht so ganz verstanden, wenn ich
ehrlich bin.
Hä?
Okay, jetzt funktioniert aus
Gründen
alles. Okay.
Okay, wie locke ich das
wieder? Ich muss wahrscheinlich,
ich muss es wahrscheinlich
exportieren.
Ich delete
auch mal alles.
Confirm Disconnect.
Und jetzt importieren wir mal. Okay.
Import Pool.
Jawoll. Import.
Und jetzt muss ich ja eigentlich
ein Passwort eingeben, oder? Wobei, an der Stelle
muss ich noch kein Passwort eingeben.
Postchamp.
An der Stelle muss ich noch kein Passwort eingeben, sondern
ich muss hier beim Unlocken.
Unlock.
Passphrase.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
Save. Continue.
Okay, jetzt
funktioniert das aus irgendwelchen Gründen viel einfacher.
Du hast das Gefühl, es ist nicht der einzige
Weg zum Locken. Hier kann man
auch noch Locken drücken.
Lock.
Bam.
Jetzt auch wieder gelockt. Unlock.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
Bam. Wieder da.
Continue. Okay, das funktioniert
schon mal ganz gut. So die Basics
mit Locken und Unlocken vom Pool. Alles gut. Alles gut.
Alles nice. Gefällt mir.
Ich muss sagen, das Webinterface finde ich ganz gut.
Das ist ein bisschen Material Design,
aber nicht so abartig Material Design.
So.
Wenn ich das mit ZFS noch richtig
in Erinnerung habe, dann ist
ein Dataset quasi
ein Ordner ist ein falsches
Wort. Sowas wie ein Ordner.
Ich glaube, in Ordner kann man das
ganz gut beschreiben. Also wo man
ein bisschen schöner
unterteilen kann. Im Prinzip sowas wie ein Ordner.
Und ein ZVOL
ist ein
eine Image
Datei,
die ich mounten kann.
Wenn ich das noch richtig in Erinnerung habe.
Also es gibt zwei Sachen.
Also wenn ich zum Beispiel eine
VM habe, die direkt
auf mein ZFS Pool gehen soll,
dann kann ich das mit einem
ZVOL machen.
Und hier kann man es mit einem Ordner
quasi irgendwie besser gruppieren.
Aber wir lassen mal das Standard.
Und weil wir können mal
Add Dataset.
Macht Junas VM? Ja doch, das probieren wir mal aus.
Also da machen wir jetzt hier einfach mal
sagen wir hier
Wirkt.
Nehme ich jetzt einfach mal.
Encryption. Case Sensitive.
Case Sensitive
ist cringe.
Share Time Generic
Samba.
Ne Samba Share will ich da nicht machen.
Advanced Options.
Read Only, Checksum.
Notification machen wir bestimmt nicht an.
Das brauche RAM as fuck.
Snapshot Directory. Copies.
Records. Okay was.
Speichern.
Für unsere VMs haben wir einen eigenen Ordner.
Jetzt haben wir noch einen eigenen Ordner.
Den nennen wir jetzt einfach mal Share.
Und der kriegt
Standard Zeug.
Der kriegt Share Type Samba.
Gucken was dann passiert.
Please wait.
Wahrscheinlich macht er Samba an jetzt.
Kann ich da jetzt schon drauf zugreifen mit Windows?
An der Stelle.
Ich habe ja weder User noch sonst was angelegt.
Ne.
Ne Moment.
Warte mal.
Ich muss ja Backslash machen.
Das ist ja Windows.
Ne geht natürlich noch nicht.
Wahrscheinlich weil
der Samba Service noch nicht läuft.
Okay.
Das heißt das ist einfach nur das
der intern sich merkt okay das wird mal
ein Samba Share.
Beziehungsweise Windows Laufwerk.
Na gut. Dann machen wir doch erstmal
die simplen Sachen ne. Windows Share.
Stop. Also wir adden ein Windows Share.
Path Mount
Qt Pool Share.
Korrekt.
Purpose Basic
Time Machine Share.
Multi User Time Machine.
Multi Protokoll Share.
Privates
SMB Dataset and Shares.
Private ist wahrscheinlich
mit Passwort.
Und das hier ist Public.
Wir machen Default Share Parameter und gut ist
Description
Enables. Save.
Enable the Service. Ja.
Dass der Samba startet.
Standardmäßig. Ist gut.
Okay. Jetzt probieren wir mal aus.
Backslash Backslash.
1 2 1.
Okay. Admin.
1 2 3 4 5 6.
Nein. Das ist anscheinend
kein standardmäßig
freigegebener User.
Also muss ich wahrscheinlich noch User definieren
vorher.
Ne. Admin hat nicht 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8.
Admin hat
nur 1 2 3 4 5 6.
Okay. User sind.
Kann man den auch einfach
Public machen ohne User?
Share.
Advanced Settings vielleicht.
Access.
Allow
Guest Access.
Okay. Den Rest habe ich keinen Plan
von Samba. Aber Allow Guest Access.
Das klingt schon mal gut.
Aha.
Okay.
Ja.
Moment.
Darauf habe ich ja auch keinen.
Moment. Ich muss auf Share.
Slash.
Ne. Passt doch eigentlich.
Das liegt nicht an Windows in dem Fall.
Das ist garantiert irgendein
ACL.
Ah. Oh. Da muss jetzt auch.
Okay. Da musst du aber viel von Hand machen.
Ja. Ich weiß, dass es notwendig ist unter Linux
das so zu machen. Ich habe auch schon Samba
von Hand installiert. Aber es ist blöd,
dass es nicht irgendwie ein bisschen
per Assistent
Es ist unnötig
kompliziert. Oder?
Owner. Jetzt muss ich
noch einstellen wie Guest gemappt wird.
Oder wie?
Build in Users. Gibt es
keine Guest Group?
Gibt es keine? Schau nochmal unter
Erweitert. Ja. Kann ich gleich machen.
Access Group.
Everyone. Das sieht gut aus.
Everyone.
Allow.
Full
Control.
Äh. Ne. Das wollen wir wahrscheinlich eher nicht.
Und wie apply ich das
jetzt?
Äh. Use
Preset. Ne. Ne.
Äh. Wo ist
der Apply Knopf?
Wo ist der Apply Knopf?
Ich finde ihn nicht.
Was macht das?
Ja. Meinetwegen.
Okay.
Wofür ist das gut?
This Action removes all
ACL vom Kern.
ACE has
Errors.
Jetzt hat es keine Errors mehr. Und jetzt funktioniert es.
Hä?
Alles gut.
Was auch immer.
Ah. Jetzt darf ich.
Jetzt darf ich.
Nice.
New.
Warum finde ich immer so komische Bugs?
Null.
Okay. Jetzt haben wir Files da drauf erstellt.
Nice.
Okay. Es ist deutlich komplexer
hier NAS Funktionalität
zu konfigurieren. Aber das liegt auch am
ZFS unten drunter. Und weil es dir halt auch
die ganzen
Options bietet. Als dreimal klicken
in Unrate.
Ist Vor- und Nachteil zugleich. Wenn man das
korrekt einstellen will. Ganz genau.
Ist es natürlich von Vorteil.
Gut. Gefällt mir
trotzdem ganz gut bisher.
Gefällt mir
trotzdem ganz gut. So. Jetzt probieren wir mal
eine Sache noch aus.
Wir machen jetzt mal einen Snapshot davon.
Weil das ist ja eines der wirklich
coolen Features von
von ZFS. Wir machen jetzt mal einen Snapshot
von.
Create Snapshot.
Wobei vorher kopieren wir mal ein bisschen was drauf.
Würde ich sagen. Oder?
Dass wir das auch mal ausprobieren können.
Dass man da ein bisschen was zu tun hat.
Aber ein bisschen was größeres was man
schon drauf kopieren kann.
Documents.
Battlefield Files.
Ist nicht so viel.
Zwo Gig.
Okay. Nice.
Ach. Man kann hier gar nicht mehr schließen.
Probieren wir mal ein bisschen Battlefield drauf.
Ja. Zwei Gig Battlefield. Da sind viele kleine
Dateien auch.
Ich mein. Hey. Brauchen wir jetzt nicht.
Weil die Platten. Das liegt eh alles bei mir lokal.
Also das ist jetzt nicht aussagekräftig
was die Performance angeht. Zumal es auch in der VM ist.
Bei mir lokal.
Also das muss ja überhaupt nicht übers Netzwerk drüber.
Also nicht übers
richtige Netzwerk.
So.
Gut.
Da ist es. Alle Files da.
Gut. Jetzt erstellen wir mal einen Snapshot.
Create Snapshot.
Manual. Name.
Pogu. Ne. Wobei. Komm. Scheiße.
Wir lassen mal den Stand. Hallo.
Darf ich nicht mehr rückgängig machen.
Naming.
Schema.
Ah. Das ist gut.
Man kann auch automatische Snapshots im Hintergrund machen.
Das ist nice.
Set include child data sets. Nö.
Hat keine child data sets.
Save.
Okay. Wir haben einen Snapshot gemacht.
Was heißt. Wenn ich jetzt zufälligerweise
rm
minus rf mache.
Hier in diesem Verzeichnis.
So. Delete four items.
Und dann auch noch ohne ECC.
Oh nein. Ja dann ist im Forum vorbei.
Dann ist.
Dann ist durch. Wenn du das da postest.
Dass du es gar ohne ECC ramm machst.
Und auch nicht mit einem Gigabyte
pro Terabyte. Dann ist eh durch.
Dann kriegst du offiziell
die Lizenz zum
TrueNAS verwenden aberkannt.
Die machen eine neue
Lizenz für dich.
GPL excluded
so nice.
Das ist dann quasi die
not so nice GPL Edition.
Gut.
So. Also ich habe jetzt aus versehen was gelöscht.
Und jetzt Restoren wir den
Snapshot mal wieder und gucken
ob das wieder da ist.
Also. Create Snapshots. Wunderbar.
Manage Snapshots.
Bis jetzt mag ich das UI.
Roll back. Hold.
Hold bedeutet das er die bei automatischem
Rotaten nicht löscht.
Okay. Clone to new data set.
Das ist natürlich auch cool.
Wenn ich beispielsweise
aus einem Backup nur einzelne Dateien
Restoren will. Das finde ich
gut das es die Option anbietet.
Du kannst beispielsweise das Ding in
einen neuen Ordner quasi
Restoren. Dir 3-4 Dateien
davon rausholen und dann wieder
wegschmeißen oder wieder. Du musst es nicht
komplett rollbacken. Und im Zweifelsfall
halt auch neue Dateien wieder löschen.
So.
Machen wir mal rollback. In dem Fall rollback.
Also. Use Snapshots.
Blablabla.
Okay. Wenn ich irgendwas neueres trenne
dann mag er nicht.
No safety check. Confirm. Rollback.
Go to storage.
Okay. Warum auch immer.
Und ist jetzt die Daten wieder da?
Die Daten sind wieder da.
Das ist doch cool oder?
Das ist natürlich. Das ist auch
was cooles. Für ein
Beispielsweise
für ein NAS
in einer kleineren Firma oder so.
Wenn sich die Sekretärin irgendeine
Malware per E-Mail eingefangen hat.
So. Und jetzt
ein anderes Beispiel.
Mal angenommen wir hätten jetzt neuere Daten.
Machen wir nochmal ein Beispiel.
So. Ich habe jetzt
neuere Daten hier drauf.
Und dann sagen wir mal so.
Moment.
Warum ist das leer?
So. Ich habe jetzt neuere Daten hier drauf.
In Kekl habe ich
beispielsweise
ein neues
Dokument angelegt.
So. Und jetzt habe ich aus versehen
meinen Battlefield Ordner wieder.
War da nicht mehr drin im Battlefield Ordner
vorher?
Nur mal so. Nur mal auf Nummer sicher zu gehen.
Ne.
Okay. Safe.
Moment. Stiebt der das jetzt
in Papierkorb? Muss ich das jetzt in Papierkorb
erst löschen, dass es weg ist?
Sekunde.
Recycle Bin. Ne.
Ist gleich weg. Gut.
So. Jetzt ist das leer. So. Jetzt gibt es
natürlich ein Problem. Ich kann jetzt
den Snapshot nicht zurückrollen.
Weil wenn ich den Snapshot zurückrolle.
Dann ist ja meine
Plup TXT weg.
Mal gucken ob er das
feststellt.
Okay.
Ich muss sagen sehr eingängiges
Web Interface gefällt mir bisher.
Manage Snapshots.
Merkt er das, wenn ich ihm jetzt sage
Rollback?
Stop on rollback.
Okay.
Ich weiß nicht ob eine einzelne Datei zählt,
die neuer ist. Probieren wir es mal aus.
Rollback.
Das hat nichts.
Die Datei ist wieder weg.
Okay. Das merkt er an der Stelle nicht.
Aber ich könnte jetzt
zum Beispiel sagen.
Also das heißt wahrscheinlich ist so zu
Restoren eh ne blöde Idee.
Wahrscheinlich ist es deutlich besser zu sagen
Clone to new Dataset.
Ja. Das nennen wir jetzt mal so.
Go to Datasets.
Und jetzt share ich dieses neue Dataset
auch nochmal
als
Share.
Add.
Mount. Qt Pool.
Share Manual. Ja. Alles gut.
Save.
The following change
will be some
request.
Wenn du meinst.
Ne.
Moment.
Mount?
Ich wollte Share.
Wait a minute. Jetzt bin ich verwirrt.
Share?
Warum heißt denn das jetzt nicht so?
Ich delete das jetzt nochmal.
Add.
Pass.
Qt Pool. Share.
Das will ich haben.
Hier. So will ich das nennen.
Genau. So will ich das nennen.
Default Share Parameters.
Ich sollte mir ein neues Preset machen.
Ich sollte mir glaube ich ein neues Preset machen.
Mit so Access für alle.
Allow Guest Access wieder.
Wobei ich eigentlich das
normalerweise gar nicht will mit Guest Access.
Ja ja. Restart.
Jetzt wird es aber.
Jetzt wird es aber Massify IQ langsam.
What the fuck.
What?
Jetzt springe ich nicht mehr durch.
Das ist mir jetzt zu hoch.
Alter.
Was will der von mir?
Okay aber wir sollten den jetzt. Okay da ist er.
Share. Ah ich darf drauf zugreifen.
Ach das hat er sich mit rüber kopiert vom anderen.
Die Dateisystemrechte. Okay logisch.
Die waren ja im
Snapshot mit drinnen.
Okay das ist die viel bessere Art einen Snapshot wiederherzustellen.
Man erstellt den Snapshot
quasi auf einem extra Laufwerk.
Kopiert sich jetzt die Dateien raus, die man ausversehen will.
Gelöscht hat.
Und danach haut man das wieder weg.
Das finde ich gut.
Das ist nice. Das gefällt mir.
So und.
Delete. Promote.
Leute ich habe es Promoted.
Was bedeutet das?
Ne Open Media Vault mag ich gar nicht.
Ich habe es Promoted.
Was bedeutet das?
Promote.
To destroy the dataset that the clone
was. Ah.
Das ist.
Ach jetzt verstehe ich es.
Jetzt könnte ich den löschen.
Weil das ja quasi der Parent
von meinem
Snapshot Restore ist.
Okay aber will ich ja gar nicht.
Den Restore löschen.
Enter Qt Chat
zum löschen.
Okay confirm.
Error.
Dependent Clones
use error.
To destroy.
Oh no.
Das ist wahrscheinlich weil ich es eben
Promoted habe.
Delete.
Ja und wie mache ich das jetzt?
Never. Geht nie wieder weg.
Für immer.
Für immer ist es da.
Ach jetzt muss ich den anderen Promoten.
Okay.
Ah man kann immer nur eins.
Okay das leuchtet ein.
Jetzt kann ich es löschen.
Achtung. Pass mal auf.
Nice. Okay.
Das ergibt irgendwie in sich geschlossen Sinn.
Das finde ich sehr nice.
Ich mag Sachen die in sich geschlossen irgendwie
logisch sind.
Ich muss sagen die Verwaltung von Netzwerk Shares
ist irgendwie
noch nachvollziehbar.
Ist aber ne ganze Ecke komplexer
als beispielsweise jetzt bei Unraid.
Ist aber nicht schlecht.
Also.
Ist gut und schlecht vielleicht gleichzeitig.
Man kann mehr machen.
Aber das ist jetzt hier auf der anderen Seite.
Du machst dir einmal ein Preset mit deinen Berechtigungen.
Stellst es ein.
Und du machst ja auch nicht jeden Tag 5 neue Shares.
Also ich glaube das ist ganz okay.
So.
Was haben wir sonst noch zu bieten?
Also Shares haben wir jetzt ausprobiert.
Dataset. Also ich probiere gleich noch das ganze
VRM Zeug und Docker Kreml aus.
Data Protection.
Resilver Priority.
Ach ja das müssen wir auch noch ausprobieren.
Was ist denn wenn eine Disk Failed?
Was ist bei einem Disk Fail?
Disk Fail. Achtung hier.
Hard Disk 32G
Settings. Löschen wir doch einfach mal eine.
Hier.
Remove.
Bäm.
Disk Fail. Mal gucken ob er
das merkt.
Der sollte mir jetzt hier irgendwas schreiben.
Alert. No Alert.
Gebated. Gibt es nicht.
Storage.
Ah.
Wie das ist kein Alert wert.
Es ist kein Alert wert das gerade meine
Festplatte verreckt ist.
Oh okay.
Wahrscheinlich muss ich es erst konfigurieren.
Also ich hätte gedacht das Fail an
Disks standardmäßig mit dabei ist.
Und ich wüsste
auch nicht wie ich es konfigurieren soll.
Ehrlich gesagt.
Es ist nicht critical wenn der Festplatte abgekackt ist.
Na gut der Pool geht noch.
Pool is degraded. Oh no.
Ne Scrap muss ich den nicht.
Okay.
Jetzt will ich den Pool.
Noch geht er.
Ach jetzt habe ich einen Alarm.
Aha. Das hat nur ein bisschen gedauert.
Okay.
VMWare Disk is Faulted.
RIP Disk.
Gut.
Ja dann muss ich den Pool jetzt
irgendwie austauschen würde ich sagen.
Also neue.
78 Errors.
Okay die Platte ist weg.
Also hängen wir eine neue Platte rein.
Moment. Falsche VM.
Hängen wir eine neue Platte rein.
Hard Disk.
Create New Virtual Disk.
32G bla bla bla.
Finish.
Okay.
Ja das ist natürlich doof wenn er das jetzt nicht erkennt
dass ich die dran gehängt habe wenn ich jetzt rebooten muss
dafür. Das ist natürlich doof.
Das ist natürlich blöd.
Das liegt aber an der VM dass er die nicht automatisch
erkennt eindeutig.
Jupp. Okay.
Wo würde ich das jetzt hinzufügen?
Storage.
Managed Devices.
Online.
Was passiert dann?
Unavailable.
Ja ach.
Natürlich ist es unavailable.
Sehr gut. Nice.
Ja. Nun gut.
Wie?
Replace.
Member Disk. SDA.
Disk is not clean.
Was? Alter.
Die Platte ist weg.
Äh.
Warum ist SDA jetzt wieder da?
Ich bin verwirrt.
Liegt das an meinem VM Kram?
Hat er das
Kann es sein
dass er die gleiche
einfach wieder erstellt hat?
Kann es sein
dass er die gleiche wieder erstellt hat?
Das ist durchaus möglich.
Jaja.
Er hat die gleiche wieder erstellt.
Eins.
Ne.
Zwei. Doch. Doch. Doch.
Eins. Drei. Vier.
Eins. Zwei. Drei.
Jaja.
Der hat die wieder erstellt.
Okay.
Also nochmal removen eine Platte.
Jetzt hat er wieder festgestellt
dass die graded ist hoffe ich mal.
Faulted. Faulted.
Okay. Und jetzt
fügen wir nochmal eine neue Platte hinzu
Der hat das alte Image
reused und das Ding hat gedacht
Ah. Die Platte ist wieder da.
Ist ja logisch.
Add New Disk.
Jetzt müssen wir die anders benennen.
Müssen wir aufpassen dass das funktioniert.
Next. Next. Next.
Create New Ding. Single File 32.
Gig.
So heißt nicht 4 sondern heißt 69.
Die gibt es auf jeden Fall noch nicht.
Alles klar. Faulted.
Gut.
Was passiert denn bei Extend?
Disc.
Achso. Da kann man alle durch ersetzen.
Also. Faulted. Replace.
Member.
Was?
Warum kann ich die nicht ersetzen?
Ach. Moment. Die habe ich vorher durch sich selbst ersetzt.
Ach.
So war das.
Der hat die neue auch wieder als SDA erkannt.
Na gut.
Hot Swap funktioniert jetzt nicht.
Weil er erkennt
nicht dass meine Disc
dran gehängt wurde.
Gut. Das heißt ich muss jetzt Rebooten.
Was ich wahrscheinlich bei einem echten System
höchstwahrscheinlich
zumindest
nicht machen müsste.
Ist immer blöd noch
den Pool besonders
zu belasten wenn eine Disc kaputt ist.
Deswegen ist es auch komplett
Also RAID 5 ist eh
ein bisschen fragwürdig wenn die Platten
besonders groß sind und wenn man dann auch noch
viele Platten drin hat dann ist RAID 5 eigentlich
ja nur eine Frage der Zeit
bis es komplett kaputt ist.
Du du du du
Ist es wieder da?
Nein es ist nicht wieder da.
Ich muss mehrere Anschlüsse definieren ohne Platte.
Hä? Wie? Anschlüsse ohne Platte?
Wie?
Wie soll ich Anschlüsse ohne Platte definieren?
Verstehe ich nicht.
Gucken wir mal gleich. Aber ich glaube nicht
dass es darüber einen Rescan gibt.
Unter Storage gab es Discs.
Nö.
Gibt es keinen Rescan.
Ich habe leider das erkannt.
Die SDB ist die Neue.
Also kann ich jetzt sagen
Add to Pool.
Ne ich will wahrscheinlich nicht sagen
Sondern ich vermute mal
Moment das liegt daran
Locked.
Ich muss es erst Unlocken.
Unlock.
7 8
IIQ Passwort continue
Close
Storage
Degraded
Unavailable
Alles klar. Replace
Replace mit dieser Disc
Alles klar. Replace Disc
Geht eigentlich
relativ easy muss man sagen.
Problematisch wird es nur wenn es mal nicht
funktioniert und dann von Hand du irgendwie mit
ZFS Tools ran musst.
Ich muss sagen
Ihr wisst ich bin immer schwer zu begeistern.
Aber ich finde es echt gut gemacht.
ZFS ist keine
easy Geschichte.
Auch hier das Interface gefällt mir bis jetzt ganz gut.
Gucken wie es mit Container
und VMs aussieht.
Aber das macht doch echt
einen guten durchdachten
managebaren
benutzbaren Eindruck.
Also bis jetzt bin ich echt positiv
überrascht was ich von den wenigsten Systemen
in der Richtung war.
Media Vault hat mir gar nicht gefallen.
Proxmox für mein Heimeinsatzgebiet nicht.
Selbst Android hat mir am Anfang
nicht gut gefallen.
Das Handling von den Shares
hier ist ok.
Man kann sogar NFS und WebDAV Shares
anlegen.
Why not?
Eigentlich ganz cool. Erden wir mal ein WebDAV Share.
Qt Pool Share.
Ich will unbedingt meinen Battlefield Ordner
sharen per WebDAV.
Lul we.
Change. Was?
Achso ne das geht nicht.
Ok. Changen wir nur mal.
Nur mal
Kekkel Userberechtigung.
WebDAV starten.
Proxmox hat auch einen Dark Mode.
Nice. Ok.
Wie ist die WebDAV Adresse davon
jetzt?
Woher weiß man das jetzt?
Was hat ein WebDAV für
einen Port überhaupt?
HTTP
ist ja schon belegt. Plus UI.
True NAS WebDAV
Port. Das sieht man
bestimmt bei Services
oder?
Wo sieht man hier Services?
Services.
WebDAV.
Ok. Port.
8080.
Admin. 123456.
Achso.
Shit man.
Dafür muss man jetzt wirklich einen User anlegen.
Aber man sieht schon mal,
dass es prinzipiell funktioniert.
Oder ich könnte vielleicht
8080 Slash
Share oder wie habe ich das genannt?
0w.
Na ne.
Da stand ein Passwort. Wirklich?
Wo? Wo?
Wo?
Habe ich das eben beim Anlegen übersehen?
Ach
beim Port. Ach bei den
System Settings
stand das.
DAV Test. Ok. Nice. DAV Test.
8080.
User. Tja. DAV Test.
DAV Test. Ne. Shit.
Ähm. Ja was ist denn das?
Was ist denn das Default Passwort?
Default User?
Admin? Ähm.
www?
Ne.
Was? UI Shell?
Oh.
Ist der User vielleicht WebDAV?
Ne.
Ja der User wäre
gut zu wissen, Leute.
Basic Authentification.
Ja aber
ich brauche doch den User dafür.
Es wird keins genannt
hier.
Ah. User leer lassen?
Ne. Geht auch nicht.
Dann weiß ich es nicht. Dann keine Ahnung.
Dann löschen
wir den Share jetzt einfach wieder.
Weil will ich eh nicht verwenden.
Gut. So. Wir haben Stem Shots ausprobiert.
Wir haben das Replaced ausprobiert. Alles nice.
Dann gucken wir uns mal die Virtualisierungs
Oh. Achso.
Ähm. Ja. Moment. Moment.
Gleich
supporten wir auch Virtualisierung.
Dauert kurz. Einmal
rebooten dazu.
Was ist unter Apps? Ich denke mal sowas wie
vorkonfigurierte Dogger Images oder sowas.
Ähm. CPU
Virtualisieren
von Intel
VTX.
Das braucht man damit Nested Virtualisierung
funktioniert. Also Leute erwartet jetzt keine Performance
Wunder.
Aber mein Rechner ist stark genug. Also es ist
schon ganz brauchbar. Selbst mit Nested
Virtualisierung
kann man, kann man durchaus benutzen.
Unter Apps ist Kubernetes
stellst. Das bezweifle ich, dass da Kubernetes
was damit ist.
Oder kann man die als Kubernetes Nodes verwenden?
Was echt totale
Zweckentfremdung wäre.
Nested funktioniert ohne Probleme. Guck.
Zack. Nested Virtualisierung.
VM ist erstellt. Wo sich
jetzt bei DHCP eine IP bootet.
Und schon ist man ratzfatz
auf einer neu erstellten
Nested Virtualisierten VM drauf.
Aber gut. Ist auch minimales Debian.
Und
außer SSH Login macht er nix.
Achso GUI.
Ja UI lasse ich ja
da drüber auch nicht laufen.
Habe ich nicht vor.
Zack. Bam sind wir auf der VM.
So. Also da kommen wir mal
unter Apps.
Choose a pool for apps.
Äh. Ganzer Pool?
Warum kein Dataset für Apps?
Wahrscheinlich macht er einen eigenen.
Failed to mount Dataset.
Kenner man gut der IX. Failed to mount
Operation not permitted.
Ok. Nice.
GG. Moment. Was?
Kubernetes stells.
Ah. Ich habe nicht Unlocked.
Ich habe ja neu gestartet.
Ja. Dann deleten wir das mal wieder.
Ich hoffe die Applications sind dann auch
Encrypted. Alles andere wäre nämlich echt
doof.
Ähm. So hier. Unlock.
Unlock. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
Bam. Bestes Passwort ever.
Close.
Apps.
Pool.
Choose. Ah.
Die haben da echt
einen Single Node Kubernetes für drunter.
Die Idee.
Ernsthaft Leute. Die Idee ist nicht doof.
Wisst ihr warum die nicht doof ist?
Weil die einfach irgendwelche Helmcharts
nehmen können.
Und deswegen haben die das
bestimmt auch so gemacht.
Die haben einfach irgendwelche Buttons im Webinterface
unter der Haube. Macht das einen Helm.
Macht das einen Helminstall.
Ja. Also die Idee ist gar nicht mal
schlecht.
Ich hoffe es. Warum sind die Applications
unencrypted? Das ist doch scheiße.
Kann man das wenigstens einschalten
im Nachhinein?
Encryption.
Ob es Stash als App gibt?
Ist Stash nicht das
Bitbucket?
Bitbucket. Ähm.
Ist Atlassian Bitbucket
Vorgänger?
Atlassian Stash.
Ja doch. Ist es.
So richtig was ich sage.
Das ist das was jetzt Bitbucket Server ist.
Ok. Apps.
Ja.
Not found. Settings.
Choose Pool. Unset Pool.
Launch. Ach man kann auch direkt ein Docker Image
starten. Finde ich auch schon mal cool.
Ok. View Catalog.
Was soll ich suchen? Stash.
Nö. Gibt es nicht.
Aber es gibt bestimmt so ekliges Zeug wie Nextcloud und sowas
was ich nicht haben will.
Moment. Das alles?
Aber nicht so viel.
Doch Home Assistant ist drinne.
Also es wäre tatsächlich was. Wobei ich ganz ehrlich
Home Assistant nicht im Kubernetes laufen
lassen würde. Ähm.
Ich finde Kubernetes ist eines der Dinger
die richtig gut in der VM sind.
Und nicht hier drinne.
Gibt noch ein Community Chart. Ok.
True NAS
Community Chart. Zeig mal her.
Ah.
True Charts
Catalog. Und das fügt man
das jetzt einfach so hinzu?
Manage Catalog. Das ist gut gemacht.
Das ist wirklich gut durchdacht.
Das gefällt mir.
Ah ja. Nervt mich.
Catalog Name.
Äh. Ja.
Community. So.
Pository.
Prefer Strain Stable. Ja meinetwegen.
Branch. Main. Ja was ist hier?
Main oder Master? Master.
Boah. Lass das mal nicht Twitter hören.
Anzeige ist raus.
Save.
Refresh.
Available Applications. Nope.
Äh. Hallo?
Ah.
Du du du du du du
Du du du du du du. Der synkt.
High IQ Sync
Action. Du brauchst
.git?
Ich denke nicht.
Ach so.
Äh.
Wait a minute.
Aha. Alles gut.
Ähm.
Wo ist mein...
Okay.
Ich muss wahrscheinlich wirklich .git machen.
Add Catalog.
Punkt Shit.
Master.
Ich vermute mal, dass ich
Master machen muss, oder?
So ein...
Ein How to Add gibt es da anscheinend nicht.
Save.
Community Catalog.
Wie ist Tuna Scale?
Also ich muss sagen, ich finde das Web Interface
und das Handling vom Store
das hat durchaus was.
Das gefällt mir bis jetzt ganz gut.
Da bin ich
bin ich zu blöd, das irgendwie
zu adden. Wie funktioniert denn das?
Funktioniert so nicht, oder?
True Charts.
Also
ich wusste irgendwie, dass es
Time Charts sind.
Äh. Docs. Getting Started.
Introduction.
Könnt ihr mir nicht einfach sagen, was ich adden muss?
Ja, aber woher weiß man das?
Aber woher weiß man
das, dass man das machen muss?
Wo steht denn das?
Wo steht, wie das funktioniert?
Okay. Man muss es...
Man muss es anscheinend wissen.
Also was muss ich adden?
Catalog.
Das da.
Das da muss ich adden.
Okay. Also noch einmal.
Ähm. Manage Catalogs.
Aber warum machen die nicht auf ihre
auf ihre Webseite
so und dann BÄM. Das einfach hinzufügen erstmal.
Dann weißt du Bescheid.
Add Catalogs.
Community. Repository.
Punkt. Shit.
Und ist das jetzt Main oder Master?
Das ist Main.
Okay. Gut.
Save.
Jobs.
Gib ihm.
Hinzufügen please.
Catalog create.
Habe ich jetzt das Richtige hinzugefügt?
Bei Punkt 4.
Make sure you can reach.
Aha.
Da.
Enterprise and stable.
Okay.
Es synkt immer noch.
Available applications.
Ist das schon ein bisschen mehr?
Ist das schon ein bisschen mehr geworden?
Aber jetzt scheint es zu funktionieren.
Das letzte Mal wäre er da schon abgebrochen.
Der wird wieder failen.
Nur ein falsches Repo. Warum?
Ich habe doch jetzt genau das Richtige rein.
Ich habe doch das da jetzt rein kopiert.
Das müsste jetzt das Richtige sein.
Das ist genau das was hier drinne steht.
Du hast aber Punkt Git angegeben.
Das sollte eigentlich keinen Unterschied machen.
Geht doch.
Aber es scheint schon mal ein bisschen mehr zu machen jetzt.
Aha.
Fertig gesynkt.
Nice.
Available applications.
Aaaah.
Ui.
Ein bisschen was drin.
Okay. So machen wir mal.
Was soll ich gucken? Stash?
Hat irgendjemand geschrieben Stash?
Das brauchen wir alles Leute.
Das brauchen wir alles Leute. Wichtig.
Wichtig.
Da war ja klar, dass der Chat irgendwie so komische Dinger
vorschlägt wieder.
True.
Brauchen wir jetzt nicht.
Es gibt ernsthaft einen
Porn Organizer?
Warum kann man das nicht organisieren wie alles andere auch?
Also warum braucht es dafür etwas
Spezielles an Software?
Okay. Testen wir einfach mal was.
Hauen wir mal das da drauf. Nur zum ausprobieren.
Ich will da nichts großartiges machen.
Ich will nämlich noch die Virtualisierung testen.
Healthy. Blablabla.
Okay.
Äh.
Und wie installiere ich jetzt was?
Ach sorry indem ich auf Install klicke.
Ja da hätte ich jetzt auch drauf kommen können.
Ich dachte das ist irgendwie in dem Popup drin.
Okay schnell im Version.
Okay das ist die neueste.
Ist das schon die?
Moment. 1.19?
Was?
Wait a minute.
1.19
released.
Okay das sind die Helm Chart Versionen.
Richtig du hast Recht.
Ja dann weiß ich ja gar nicht welche das
im Endeffekt unten drunter installiert.
Na gut.
Desired Replicas.
Jetzt mal ernsthaft Leute. Macht es irgendwie Sinn?
Also kann man das?
Man kann dann
man kann auch theoretisch sogar mehrere Kubernetes
Nodes damit wahrscheinlich sogar irgendwie machen.
Aber das werden die wahrscheinlich nicht über das
Web Interface supporten.
Wobei ich dann auch was anderes als Tunas nehmen würde
dafür.
Okay Time Zone ist
Berlin, Europe
Ist eigentlich scheiß egal zum ausprobieren.
Admin Credentials
Admin 123456
Passwort
kekel at kappa0.com
Run Production Mode
Load Host List
Node IP
Exposed Ports
Load Balancer
Haben die da Metal LB oder sowas dabei?
Das es mit Local IPs funktioniert?
Ah!
Die haben es tatsächlich
Metal LB drauf.
Okay Port 10.037
SSH Service
Brauche ich eigentlich gar nicht.
Kann ich den ausschalten?
Kann ich den?
Ich will den
SSH Port gar nicht exposen.
PVC Storage alles klar.
Okay
Ich installiere
Ich installiere jetzt einfach mal.
Die haben Ingress dabei.
Okay Leute das ist
Da kommst du aber als Noob nicht weiter
Wenn du nicht ein bisschen Kubernetes Erfahrung hast.
Welchen Ingress verwenden die?
Wahrscheinlich hauen die mir da noch irgendwie einen Nginx oder sowas drauf.
Aber wenn ich einen Ingress verwende
Dann bräuchte ich eigentlich
Kein Load Balancer.
Machen wir mal ohne.
Okay das ist richtig.
Moment ich glaube
Dieses Chart
Ist nicht Customized für
Tunas sondern generell
Das zeigt einfach alle Dinge an
Die das Kubernetes
Helm Chart
Hergibt.
Das heißt das muss jetzt hier drauf gar nicht mal großartig funktionieren.
Okay das ist das
Dann ist es vielleicht doch nicht so sinnig.
Aber was gut ist man kann
Docker Container darin starten.
Ich hab die Documentation gecheckt.
Wir probieren mal.
Moment Qt App.
Wo ist die Qt App?
Die installieren wir jetzt.
Leute Docker Container
Wird jetzt hinzugefügt.
Releases.
Qt App.
Gut das wir die letztens erstellt haben.
Moment nicht Releases.
Packages.
Qt App wird installiert.
Alles klar.
Okay ehrlich gesagt ich bin mir nicht sicher
Ob ich dieses Feature
Benutzen werde.
Launch Docker Image.
Core ist glaube ich noch free in us.
Application Name.
Qt App.
Moment.
Hä?
Was will der von mir?
Version?
Auf welche Version
Bezieht sich das hier oben jetzt?
Die Docker Version oder?
Oder was soll das sein?
Wir lassen einfach mal alles
Die
Okay Port Forwarding.
Container Port 80.
Node Port
Irgendwas
Gucken wir mal ob jetzt die Qt App gleich funktioniert.
Storage
Volumes braucht
Braucht das alles nicht.
Okay das ist schon eine gewisse
Komplexität.
Bluefin
Was ist Bluefin?
Only paid.
Ah okay nö.
Okay wo ist unsere Qt App?
Install Application. Da ist es.
Schauen wir mal.
1 2 1 2 1 2 1.
9000.
Was habe ich gesagt?
910.
Nope.
Das ist ziemlich kompliziert das Handling.
Muss ich sagen.
Https.
Müsste kein HTTPS sein.
Ja ne anscheinend.
Kann man sich jetzt Logs angucken?
Logs?
Das heißt dann EX Chart.
Das Container.
Hä?
Was will der von mir?
Es war noch Deploying?
Ah ist immer noch am Deployen.
Also die die die
Das
Das Image ist Public.
Also der kann jetzt
Sollte das nicht so lange brauchen.
Aber mein Token ist mal wieder abgelaufen.
Okay.
Deploying.
Tja und woher weiß ich jetzt ob es irgendwie hängt?
Fail to pull Image.
Okay.
Aber das funktioniert.
Aber das geht.
Du hast kein Latest Tag.
Ich habe ihm aber gesagt das er Latest benutzen soll.
Ah.
Ach Moment habe ich das
Vielleicht nur unter einer Versions und gar nicht
Nochmal unter Latest gepusht.
Okay dann liegt das an mir.
Ja ja okay okay.
Machen wir nochmal.
Kein Ding.
Ah auf Terminator Qt App.
Launch Dock Image.
Ich weiß nicht was er mir
Mit dieser Version sagen will.
So.
Latest Tag.
Und den Rest lassen wir so.
Ach fuck ich habe die Ports vergessen.
Shit.
Okay aber zumindest das Download soll jetzt funktionieren.
Ja.
Hat funktioniert.
Ah jetzt active.
Edit.
Ports.
Port forwarding.
Container Port 80.
Save.
Okay jetzt aber.
1.2.1.2.1.2.1.
Slash 90 10.
Q Chat. Ah ja ja.
Also Handling mit
Docker Container ist nice.
Ich muss sagen die
Das Helm Chart Handling
Und das alles
Ja.
Da weiß ich ehrlich gesagt
Noch nicht ob mir das
So gut gefällt.
Ich meine wir können ja mal was einfaches installieren.
Ja.
Wie heißt dieses
Dieses eine Wiki
Was so beliebt ist bei den ganzen
Self Hosted Leuten.
Bit.
Ne.
Book Stack.
Was gibt es?
Gibt es Doku Wiki auch?
Das ist auch easy.
Okay.
Kann nicht viel schief gehen.
Ah ja.
Admin. 1.2.3.4.5.6.
Full Name.
Doku Wiki.
Doku Wiki E-Mail.
Kapalul.com.
Doku Wiki Name. Hatten wir doch gerade schon.
Enable PHP
Configuration. Was?
Äh.
Load Balance.
Exposed Ports. Ja. Okay.
Main Service
Ports.
Ingress.
Moment. Das hat ein
Ingress dabei. Da müsste ich jetzt
den DNS Namen drüber
Ding. Sonst will ich ja nicht.
Verstand er was von Ports?
Ich bin verwirrt.
Das wird
wahrscheinlich ohne Ingress so nicht gehen.
Okay. Wir installieren es einfach mal.
Wir installieren es
jetzt einfach mal und gucken ob dann irgendwas
irgendwas ist auf dem Port. Und dann installieren wir
noch eine Debian VM.
Debian
Image download. Wir laden uns schon mal
eine Debian Image runter.
Official Image Stable
Yo yo. Gepair.
Debian Net Install.
Jawoll.
Wir installieren das jetzt. Wir installieren nicht
das Minimal Image.
Will wissen ob das alles funktioniert. Ähm.
Hat das jetzt funktioniert?
Deploying. Immer noch.
Successfully. Successfully.
Successfully.
Find ich nice. Umso mehr
Successfully umso besser.
Aber ist immer noch Deploying wahrscheinlich weil der
Load Balancer nicht funktioniert. Der Load Balancer
funktioniert nicht. Weil ähm.
Wir nicht in der Cloud Umgebung sind und kein Metal LB
haben. Also
das wundert mich jetzt. Okay das ist
von der Handhabung her tatsächlich nicht so
nice. Ja muss man
wirklich mal sagen.
Ah ja. Aber mit dem Port geht
es. Er steht allerdings weiter auf
Deploying. Ach jetzt steht es auf Active.
Die haben nen Metal LB dabei
anscheinend oder?
Das muss ich jetzt mal ganz kurz checken.
sudo
minus i
cubectl. Ah ne.
Ist ja doof natürlich dass da kein cubectl
dabei ist. Muss ich jetzt einrichten
dass ich mich auf den Cluster connecte.
Achso.
Ah. Ah.
Okay. Get ports
minus minus all namespaces.
Metal LB.
Sag ich doch. Habe ich doch richtig
predicted. Ein Prometheus
Operator das man sogar
Metriken
abfragen kann.
Es ist möglich das es in K3S integriert ist.
Ich habe K3S noch nie ernsthaft mir
angeschaut. Könnte man vielleicht auch mal machen.
Sehr schick. Also
die Idee dahinter der Kubernetes
darunter zu verwenden finde ich
eigentlich gar nicht schlecht.
Auch die Anzeige mit
dem Port finde ich okay.
Also das hat was. Das sammelt bei
mir Pluspunkte. Das hat wirklich
was. Das gefällt mir.
Das haben die nämlich so gemacht dass
man sich relativ wenig Gedanken um
den Kubernetes
Shit unten darunter machen muss. Die Sache ist.
Wenn mal wirklich
was nicht läuft und du über das
Web Interface nicht weiterkommst dann bist du
ja noch komplett aufgeschmissen als jemand
der sich nicht
im Detail bisher mit Kubernetes beschäftigt hat.
Also ob das
so eine gute
Idee ist.
Weiß nicht. Ich finde den Ansatz
sinnvoll weil so kann man auf die
30 Milliarden Helmschatz zurückgreifen die es halt
gibt.
Managed Docker Images. Ne.
Also Docker Compose Files kann man einfach
anscheinend nicht
importieren. Sehe ich jetzt hier nirgends
wo.
SSH. SSH kann man höchst
wahrscheinlich
enablen.
Standardmäßig nicht enabelt.
Kann man machen.
Autostart. Port 22 wahrscheinlich.
Ja.
Das funktioniert.
SSH 1.1.1.1
2.1.1
Yes. Äh nicht als Max.
Als Admin.
Äh ok.
Gut.
Mein Router hat aber kein
sinnvolles Passwort.
Ok. Da muss man wahrscheinlich
Keys hinterlegen für den SSH Server.
Ähm.
Wenn ich jetzt wüsste wie man
Keys hinterlegt.
Egal. Guck ich mir jetzt nicht an. Kriegt man bestimmt raus.
Ich will mir nämlich auch das Virtualisierungs
Feature angucken.
Man ist nicht wirklich gerettet wenn der
SSH Server geht.
Dann muss man immer noch durchblicken.
Wie man im Zweifelsfall irgendwelche
gefailten Kubernetes Helm Deployments
fixt.
Es gab dort die Option mit Admin with Password.
Ja. Aber Admin darf sich nicht
einloggen und. Oder wo?
Hier bei. Bei SSH
oder wo?
Achso.
Ok. Chat ist es gut
dass ihr dabei seid. Weil manchmal
fällt mir sowas gar nicht auf. Was hat er hier
für Schmerzen? SSH Login
Ja. Ja. Ja. Ist ja gut.
Aha.
Da sind wir. Und jetzt dürfen wir
root werden.
Ja. Get Pots
Äh.
Jup.
Jup. CTL
All name.
Man kann auch minus A machen.
Da bist du lost wenn du dich damit noch nie beschäftigt
hast. Jemand der sich damit noch nie beschäftigt hat
weiß ja nicht mal dass man sich so überhaupt was anzeigen lassen kann.
Also das ist auf jeden Fall
was was auf den ersten Blick easy und praktisch
aussieht. Aber dann wenn was nicht
geht. Hast du Probleme und.
Na gut. Du kriegst zumindest immer deine
Daten raus. Hoffe ich.
Hoffe ich. DF minus H
Wow.
Ja gut. Das ist halt ZFS. Und Docker
ZFS mit Docker Images. Das sieht halt so aus.
Da ist halt vorbei.
Da blickst du dann immer durch. Hier.
Volumes. Secret.
Doku. Wiki. Volumes. Alles klar.
Hahaha.
Fuck man. Wo hängt das?
Wo hängt das?
Volumes. Hier.
Ah hier. Hier.
Hier. Okay.
Volumes.
Wie komm ich denn jetzt?
Alter. Alter. Also.
Releases.
Qt App 2.
Ah gut.
Die haben keine Volume.
Ich leg mal kurz im
Doku Wiki was
an und create this page.
Bla bla bla bla bla bla bla. Ganz toll.
Ja super. Jetzt haben wir eine Seite im Doku Wiki.
CD. Doku Wiki.
Wie komm ich da jetzt auf die?
Falls ich da irgendwas von Hand fixe.
Okay. Legt nix drin.
Haben die keine Volumes?
Liegt das alles intern in irgendeinem
Import oder so?
Und dass man. Weiß nicht. Gibt eigentlich auch keinen Sinn.
So dass das.
Ne. Hier sind keine Daten drin.
Dann ist die Frage. Wo das.
Wo die Daten von den.
Hallo.
Dann ist die Frage wo die Daten von
dem ganzen Zeug liegen.
Also wir haben Releases. Doku Wiki.
Ach. Ah. Und hier haben
wir noch. Hier haben wir noch die.
Die Volumes.
Okay. Ja da muss
man sich auf jeden Fall auch ein bisschen Gedanken machen
zum Storage. Wo man
den Krempel hinhaut.
Weil. Im Zweifelsfall
kommste nimmer dran.
Pages.
Hier.
Start.
Das ist meine Seite.
Na das ist natürlich ein bisschen komplizierter durch zu blicken.
Okay.
Und was ich auch ein bisschen doof finde ist das das nicht
standardmäßig Encrypted ist.
Das kann man aber bestimmt nachträglich
einschalten. Geh ich mal von aus.
Gut. Jetzt installieren wir nochmal eine VM.
Das ist nämlich auch ein Feature was mich interessiert.
Ich. Das gefällt mir aber bis jetzt tatsächlich ganz gut.
Es ist.
Deutlich komplexer als das Unraid Handling.
Ja.
Oh wir haben nur.
Wir haben nicht so viel.
Ich beende mal kurz meine.
Na gut. Das Komponentes Zeug
braucht halt RAM.
So. Add Virtual Machine.
Guest Operating System. Linux.
Debian heißt das jetzt.
Clock. Local.
Yep Clock.
Start und Boot. VNC. Bind.
Okay. Next.
Find ich ganz gut gemacht.
Wobei ich persönlich mag ja
Interfaces in der Mitte.
Was ist der Sinn davon das ich hier die Hälfte
des Fensters nicht benutze. Gell.
Ist ja auch irgendwie unsinnig.
Force 2 das ein bisschen schneller geht.
Custom Memory 512
reicht voll und ganz.
Next. Disks.
10G ist auch okay.
Hier in Wirt.
Kommt das rein.
Adapter Type.
Ich will bestimmt nicht die
Wirt IO. Kann das garantiert.
Mac. Attached to NIC.
Okay das wird
ein.
Es wird eine
Bridge sein an der das dran hängt.
Alles.
Wow. Alter.
Okay.
Next.
Installation Video. Upload Installer
Image. Yep.
Choose File.
Download.
Debian Net Install.
.
. .
Ziemlicher, ziemlicher Crap. Ich habe Webdev nur den Ordner unterschrieben, zumindest war das mein Ziel.
Good Pool, Isus, weißt du was wir jetzt machen?
Debian Image Download.
Weget?
Haha.
Outdated, overrated, jebaited.
Damit hätte er nicht gerechnet.
Es hat so ein paar Kleinigkeiten immer, wo man sich fragt, warum ist das jetzt passiert, aber das kann durchaus auch an meiner
an meiner Bedienung liegen.
Isus. Ha, da ist doch ein Debian Net Install.
Next.
Hide from MSR.
Alles klar, war ich sofort, aber
ja genau, mein VGA Adapter will ich da unbedingt passthroughen.
Okay, save, please, geh halt einfach.
Autostart.
Stoppt.
Start, okay, Display? Was jetzt?
Oh, genau, Popups, ja.
Oh, oh, ja, ist ja gut, reg dich ab.
Okay, Install.
Funktioniert doch ganz gut.
Little Memory, Alter, du hast 512 MB, jetzt, jetzt mach mal hier nicht, mach mal hier nicht Auge.
Berlin, nee, Germany, Germany, please.
Guck mal, für Nested Virtualisierung geht das doch voll klar.
Kann man sich nicht beschweren, meine Frage ist, ob das ins Internet kommt, ob das Netzwerktechnisch funktioniert und dann würde mich interessieren, welche IP hat sich's gezogen, hat es gepridged nochmal, hat es, das sehen wir gleich, Domain Name, juckt mich nicht.
123456, bestes, bestes Root Passwort aller Zeiten, äh, Max, User, 123456, 123456, immer die, einfach nur die Best Practice, besten Passwörter aller Zeiten.
Ja, DHCP kann aber auch...
Kann aber auch sein, dass es sich gezogen hat von irgendeiner internen Bridge und nicht von meinem, von meinem, äh, Mikrotik-Router, kann ich, ich könnte jetzt im DHCP nachgucken, aber ich gucke einfach gleich auf dem System dann.
Also, Leute, für Nested Virtualisierung flutscht das doch eigentlich ganz gut, oder? Kann man doch nichts sagen.
Hat Trunas eine Firewall?
Weiß nicht, ob man da bestimmte Sachen blocken kann, aber die beste Variante dürfte doch sein, einfach nur Ports und Services einzuschalten, die man braucht.
Also, ich wüsste jetzt auch nicht, also ich sehe keine und ich wüsste auch nicht genau, na doch, man könnte vielleicht, man könnte vielleicht Netze, Netze blocken von wo es kommt, also...
Sieht nicht so aus.
Network vielleicht, ja, tatsächlich, Interfaces, Static Routes, oh, okay, guck mal, man kann sogar, man kann sich sogar als OpenVPN-Client irgendwo dranhängen.
Kann nicht mal so schlecht.
Also, sieht nicht aus, als hat es irgendwie Firewall-Funktionalität.
Läuft auf Trunas auf dem Pi? Gibt es Trunas für ARM?
No.
Nein, läuft nicht.
Connect.
Scanning your installation, was?
Oh, Germany.
Irgendwie hat er sich beim Reconnecten ein bisschen mein, ein bisschen den, den, irgendwie das Terminal kaputt gemacht beim Reconnecten gerade, oder?
Wollen wir nicht Refresh machen oder sowas?
Disconnect, Reconnect, ne, das ist jetzt, das ist broken, Alter.
Hat dieses WebVNC nicht irgendwie was zum Bildschirm-Refreshen?
Äh, anscheinend nicht.
Sieht jetzt ein bisschen kaputt aus.
No.
VMs haben aber gerade in Scale einen komischen Bug, sagt der Chat.
Der komische Design, das Design ist, die VMs können netzwerktechnisch nicht auf alles zugreifen, was innerhalb von Scale läuft.
Hat mich bei meiner Home, ja, das liegt wahrscheinlich daran, weil das, äh, über MacVTab geht und da kannst du nicht auf Sachen im Haus zugreifen.
Da müsstest du eine extra Bridge einrichten, genau.
Ja.
Das ist normal, das ist kein, kein, äh, Design-Decision.
Das ist...
Also, das ist eine, eine Limitierung von diesem Netzwerktreiber, den die verwenden.
Äh, ich weiß ja nicht so genau, was das hier gerade macht, aber...
Ich will kein Debian Desktop Environment.
Die dürfen nicht, die dürfen nicht, die müssten direkt eine Bridge einrichten, sonst funktioniert das nicht.
Ja, BSD hat das anders gelöst, ja.
Ja, übrigens, dass das so kaputt ist, liegt nur daran, weil ich mich irgendwie disconnected hab, eben mit VNC.
Das ist jetzt ein bisschen, ist ein bisschen durcheinander gekommen.
Deswegen ist es cool, wenn man gerade, wenn man Netzwerkkarten hat, die Virtualisierung unterstützt, dann hast du das Problem nicht.
Die haben ja quasi intern dann nochmal Verbindungen eingebaut.
Ja, das ist immer, wenn man MacVTab verwendet.
Da kannst du aufs Netzwerk zugreifen, aber nicht auf den gleichen Host.
Installation ist complete.
Nice.
Requesting reboot.
Nein, nein.
Keine Install.
Äh, wie hänge ich denn jetzt das...
Moment, jetzt muss ich ja das, das ISO wieder aushängen.
Das ist ja nice, also es ist doof, dass das ISO drin geblieben ist.
Boot local, gibt's da auch sowas wie?
Boot, einfach weiter local booten?
Nö.
Ähm, wie hänge ich das ISO wieder aus?
Jetzt wird's, Devices?
Disk.
CD-ROM.
Details?
Äh, also, löschen wird's jetzt ja wahrscheinlich nicht sein, oder?
Edit?
Einfach löschen?
Nee.
Ich kann's löschen, aber das müsste, man muss es doch aushängen können.
Dann spätestens auch bei USB.
Ey, das ist echt blöd.
Okay.
Naja, das VM-Handling ist nicht so geil, das gefällt mir nicht.
Ey, wobei es nicht so ein großer Unterschied ist zu...
Zu Unraid, da ist es auch nicht so, so der Wahnsinn.
Devices?
CD-ROM?
Wie kommt man jetzt wieder zurück?
Nur hier drüber?
Fehlt da ein Button?
Nein.
Jetzt Proxmox Intruder.
Moment, bootet der jetzt nicht mehr?
Seriously, der bootet nicht mehr, wenn ich das CD-ROM, weil die Settings jetzt im Arsch sind, oder was?
Oh, come on, das ist doch Müll.
Das, nee, nee, nee.
Also, das sind so Basic-Dinger, die sollten eigentlich funktionieren von den...
Der muss halt eine ordentliche XML generieren, Philipp Wirth, dass das funktioniert.
Jetzt stimmt die Bootreihen-Folge nicht und er ist irgendwie abgekackt, ja.
Oder...
Oder die Installation hat nicht funktioniert.
Das kann natürlich auch sein.
Ja, ne.
Device Manager.
Devices List.
Äh, Moment.
Boot Manager.
Die Installation hat nicht funktioniert.
Die Installation hat...
Aber die Installation war doch fertig.
Der hat doch gesagt, es ist abgeschlossen, oder nicht?
Oder habe ich mir irgendwie was...
Ja doch, ich habe ja sogar rebooted nach Installation.
Ah, okay, da stimmt mit den Settings noch irgendwas nicht.
Bisschen doof.
Dass es nicht geht.
Deswegen hat er auch...
Das ist auch der Grund, warum er das überhaupt gebootet hat von...
Von Disc nochmal.
Hättest du nicht nehmen sollen?
Das ist Default-Setting.
Da erwarte ich, dass das 2023 geht.
Bei mir lokal funktioniert das ja auch.
Ah, jetzt geht das Ausschalten nicht, weil ich kein QEMU-Agent habe.
Und es gibt kein Force-Power.
Doch, Power-Off gibt es.
Die weiß es.
Add CD.
Okay, hier kann ich wenigstens...
Ja, das ist noch nicht so rot.
Also das VM-Handling ist irgendwie nicht so schick.
Irgendwie nicht so geil.
Kann man das XML...
Kann man das XML vielleicht direkt...
Moment, uah.
Ja.
Kann man vielleicht das XML direkt editieren hier?
Boot-Methode.
Legacy BIOS.
Ja, aber das kann doch nicht sein, dass man das umstellen muss.
Enlightments Hyper-V.
Nein, nein, nein.
Wir werden nicht enlightened durch Hyper-V.
Komm, du kriegst das 1024 MB, meinetwegen.
Also, da...
Ich weiß nicht.
Also, das bin ich der Meinung, das muss mit UEFI funktionieren.
Ansonsten ist irgendwas grundsätzlich kaputt.
Nee, Boot-Methode.
Boot-Methode war's nicht.
War's nicht.
Klicken wir das jetzt nochmal schnell durch.
Boot-Methode ist nicht das Problem.
Das wird trotz CD-ROM einfach funktionieren.
Ja, United States, American...
Irgendwas ist mir doch egal.
Einfach weiter.
Und dass sie nicht zugreifen können, standardmäßig, auf die Dienste, die da drauf laufen, ist auch doof.
Also, ich muss sagen, man muss da relativ viel aufpassen, dass man das Richtige macht.
Und...
Dann auch ein bisschen da rumbasteln von Hand.
Also, insgesamt gefällt's mir eigentlich ganz gut.
Auch das Webinterface punktet schon irgendwo.
Aber ich seh's mich jetzt nicht lokal verwenden.
Na, noobsicher ist es nicht.
Was?
Noobsicher ist es definitiv nicht.
Ja, aber manchmal brauchst du halt VMs.
Zum Beispiel Home Assistant betreibt man am besten in der VM.
Unabhängig davon.
Ich weiß, dass es das als Helm-Chart gibt, aber das ist, naja, fragwürdig.
Also, ich find Home Assistant ist in der VM immer noch das Beste, wie man's betreiben kann.
Allein schon, weil du dann die ganzen Home Assistant-Plugins gescheit verwenden kannst.
Ja, und so Device-Path-Through per USB in so ner VM ist auch easy und da kann sich Home Assistant drum kümmern.
Also, VM ist schon ne sinnvolle Geschichte.
Und das Handling ist jetzt...
...nicht so geil, bis jetzt.
So ist der Unterschied zwischen Docker und Helm-Chart.
Helm-Chart ist ein Inst...
Also, ganz simpel gesagt, ja?
Helm-Chart ist ein Installations-Skript für Kubernetes.
Wie du Anwendungen in deinen Kubernetes-Cluster installieren kannst.
So ein Package-Manager nennen sie sich offiziell, aber es ist eher...
...es ist eigentlich eher so ein Install-Skript.
Was Kubernetes-Ressourcen anlegt und applied im Cluster.
Was? No, will ich nicht extra scannen.
Jaja, weiter, weiter, weiter.
Ja, und Docker ist ein...
...Linux-Container-Frontend.
Ja, aber das...
So nice, das will ich nicht.
Ich will nicht TrueNAS in Proxmox dann haben.
Nur, dass ich ein Web-Interface für Laufwerk-Shares hab und sowas.
Deswegen finde ich das mit Android auch, wie gesagt, ich weiß, dass ich am Anfang ein bisschen gebasht hab...
...eigentlich ganz gut.
Wahrscheinlich ist im Heimbereich so ein Synology NAS wirklich noch das...
...einfachste, wenn man keinen Bock hat, sich da irgendwie mit was zu beschäftigen.
Das Einfachste und auch das wirklich Einzigste, wenn's noobsicher sein muss.
Oder halbwegs noobsicher mit vielen Features.
Bei Synology hat man leider keine 4Ms.
Doch, oder?
Das ging doch früher.
Ah, haste da 4Ms.
Da, Virtual Machine Manager.
Klar.
Installation is complete.
Okay, der verkackt es wohl mit Docker.
Pass mal auf, jetzt bootet er wieder nicht.
Ja.
Okay.
Also das mit 4Ms kannst du vergessen.
Damit hat's bei mir schon mal verloren.
Das kannst du dann schon mal vergessen.
Also wenn da 4Ms nicht ordentlich funktionieren.
Klar, man kann's jetzt auf BIOS umstellen und sowas.
Aber das ist halt, das ist halt unsinnig.
Ne, Proxmox eignet sich für meinen Anwendungsfall daheim nicht gut.
Edit.
Aber das geht jetzt natürlich nicht, wenn ich es im UEFI-Mode installiert hab.
Naja, das ist doof.
Also die 4M-Handling gefällt mir nicht.
Power off.
So, wie löscht man das jetzt?
Delete.
Post it.
S.
Bäh.
Alles weg.
Das ist kein BSD mehr.
Ne, das ist mittlerweile Linux.
Ich glaub, das hat jetzt als Übersicht eigentlich ganz gut gereicht.
Von der Zeit her, es ist 22 Uhr, passt auch wunderbar.
Dass das viel RAM und CPU fressen soll.
Ja gut, Kuba, nee, das Zeug hat halt auch einen gewissen Management-Overhead.
Was, wenn das startet, hast du erst mal mindestens 10 verschiedene Management-Container?
Hotz.
Am Start.
Joa.
Also, was soll ich sagen?
Es ist insgesamt...
Es hat sowohl...
Hat mich auf der einen Seite einen guten Eindruck gemacht und auf der anderen Seite nicht so
einen guten Eindruck.
Schwer zu sagen.
Also...
Die 4M-Funktionalität gefällt mir gar nicht.
Dass es ein Kubernetes ist mit Helm-Chart, Frontend, ist eine gute Idee.
Aber, ähm...
aus Features und einfachem
benutzen. Was halt dumm an Unraid ist,
dass die bei manchen Sachen
lahm as fuck sind.
Wollt ihr was fixen
mit den Docker-Problemen und sowas?
Oh, Junas.
Okay, great. Junas wieder
weg.
Unraid bekommt auch ZFS. Ja, wie gut da
das Frontend sein wird, sein wird
erstmal dahingestellt, weil ganz im Ernst,
das Unraid Frontend ist
bestenfalls okay. Also
Preis gewinne ich
für das Frontend nicht.
Aber ich finde den, ich finde den
Feature-Kombination, nein, nein, nein,
ich geh jetzt weg. Ich finde die Feature-Kombination
ganz gut.
Leute, ich geh ins Bett.
Wir sehen uns.
Macht's gut, bis denn. See you.
Bad kid time.
Wir haben's noch nicht fertig gemacht.
Ich musste dann MMO-Kreisel-Crime
machen gehen. Vielleicht sollten wir das auch demnächst
äh
vielleicht sollten wir das demnächst mal fertig machen.
Harvester, das ist
Rancher-Zeug, oder?
Nee. Oder? Oder was ist?
Was ist das?
Ich predige jetzt irgendwie mit Rancher in Verbindung im Hinterkopf.
Tatsächlich, die Nass-Funktionalität
für den Heimbereich in Unraid ist komplett
in Ordnung. Du kannst mit zwei Klicks
einen Share anlegen.
Ja, eigentlich.
Ja, du meinst, du meinst das Rancher-Harvester-Ding.
Alles klar, Leute.
Wir sehen uns. Bis denn. See you.